Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Nick the Paolo,
Ladies and gentlemen,
Joey,
boy.
Nick.
How do we become old men that don't
understand computers and technology
anymore?
Uh,
that happened even.
Even if I was 20,
I still wouldn't get it.
I'm not smart enough.
Stop.
Stop being so hard on yourself.
Your boy Jamie seems to have a grasp on
it.
Jamie's Jermel no,
he's just on the ball.
He just understands shit.
You understand certain shit that.
Is there anything that I understand that
you don't understand a lot of shit about
cars or was it a net rate and chicks?
Right.
What happens in a lot of thing about
cars,
but that's just because you don't,
you don't pay attention to cars.
It doesn't register it.
Some of it just,
it goes in and out.
Costa.
I've heard about it a lot.
Some things with electronics is the same
way.
There's certain level of electricity.
I'm scared of all music and stuff like
that.
I just started.
I don't want to die,
so I just stopped listening.
My Buddy Jimmy did teleo from Newton,
Newton mass.
He is an electrician and one of the guys
that he used to work with,
I'll never forget this,
he was telling me that this.
Oh look,
someone likes to fucking hear the Ding
every time.
The testicles.
No,
I don't.
Um,
that's how bad I'm shutting enough
electricity.
Who was working with this guy and uh,
I don't remember what he was working on,
but the guy just got just totally
zapped,
blew off his,
his,
all of his skin.
His fucking ears have gone.
His eyelids are gone.
I mean,
it just became a monster but survived.
And I'll never forget that.
I'll never forget him telling me about
that guy.
And from that moment on,
from when I was 16,
I've been fucking terrified of
electricity.
Yeah,
because you can't see it and shit.
That's crazy.
We live in a box,
right?
And in the walls of this box is this
fucking invisible thing that if you
stick a fork in there,
it'll kill you.
Just blow your fucking brains out.
Well,
it actually does.
It's like a fail safe.
Right?
If you stick a fork,
you just get a horrible jolt.
That's the thing.
I don't know what isn't that?
That's the difference between
alternating current and direct current,
right?
Isn't it?
If I knew that answer,
I wouldn't be afraid of it.
Well,
apparently in England they have a far
higher level of electricity that's going
through their walls.
Yeah.
Because the shit when you go over the
special adapt as it just kills every
stupid.
We let this two people live in England.
If you stick a fork in the wallet,
good finds your whole family kills them
to be super powerful.
I was changing the filter.
I have a generator,
a generator,
you know it runs on natural gas and
shit.
Oh,
because the winter comes one winter.
I live at the end of a dirt road in the
woods.
So when when the power goes out,
mind use the first house to go out and
it kicks right.
It's the best thing I ever did,
but I'm out there like fucking changing
the filter on and then all the sudden I
look over and his little instructions
like on the inside of the door saying,
you have to disconnect the battery when
we went down and you're not.
I got like a can of coke in my hand.
I can see what a screwdriver in your
mouth.
I am frightened that I would.
I lived in Colorado.
We had one of those.
It was running on propane,
so when the power would go,
it's awesome.
The power would go out.
We go to click and then you would hear
it immediately and one second and just
let them.
It's.
I had the guy that told me the house
told me to get it.
He had like a small one.
He.
She said you should get her,
you know,
does yours run on propane?
Yeah,
it's 250 gallons that last a long time
to write 250 gallons of Iran for.
We had last year we had a storm and the
power went out and ran for two and a
half days and it only moved the needle
like a little.
It was like,
this is the fucking balls man.
I know.
It is kind of crazy how little it uses.
Yeah.
When I'm that big storm hit,
was that like a year or two years ago
with the one where there was no food and
people are going to Dunkin donuts and up
all the songs.
There was nothing there.
It just goes to show you how God damn
fragile.
Our whole structure is.
We have this false sense of security
that much more so over there than over
here.
Over here at least it doesn't get cold,
but over there,
you know when,
when you get trapped in snow's,
you're kind of fucked.
Like I just got back from New York.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just flew back yesterday and I was
supposed to fly in on Thursday,
but they got,
they got hit with 14 inches and
everything just shut down.
They just canceled the flight.
I was headed to Chicago.
Mind got canceled.
So,
uh,
then the,
the airlines like that through your
favor,
they send you a text like at three in
the morning while you're sleeping.
Exactly.
Find you another bucking.
Oh,
that's great.
It's a fucking Laguardia,
which is 48 miles from my house.
It's at 7:00
AM.
You sitting in seat 48 only.
Thanks.
I had to change in Louisville and I did
that.
And the uh,
we sat on the tarmac to tarmac for two
hours because that was fun.
This is why I don't do the routing
people out here yell at me.
You never come to California.
I go,
I'll drive to New Jersey.
You make the same money one night also.
It's hard to get out here in the winter
especially.
Yeah.
I was on the tarmac yesterday and they
had a d ice and then we apparently sat
on the runway too long.
We had to go back and dis again.
Whatever I'll.
Complainant used to take six months to
go over here on a horse.
No,
but it's,
it's still fucking aggravating,
I mean is to ride horses.
They used to take a horse with a wooden
wheeled fucking sled behind it and you
should know that and your baby would be
on the sled with your wife and everyone
would be scared of Indians.
They still do that and tells us.
I don't think they do that anymore.
I actually,
I actually.
But people make fun of the flyover
states and and I,
I sit in New York traffic because I now
live in the suburbs.
I'm going to ask you,
I have to drive into the city and the
car.
The mayor does not want cars on a city.
He's made it impossible.
There's bike lanes on both sides of the
skateboard lanes is lanes for old
people.
This is in New York City.
Doesn't move.
Oh yeah.
No.
The city doesn't work.
Change the lanes.
Oh fuck you.
You can't.
You can't,
you,
you should not bring your car in.
And I do all the time like an idiot and
I'm.
Well I'm sitting in the Ed and then
complaining in my car.
I,
you know,
I would
fucking kill to live in Tulsa right now.
Eight minutes downtown to pick up
something.
Everybody has a totally different
opinion of the flyover states now that
trump's president.
They're like,
oh,
they get to vote to he.
Yeah,
exactly.
I always liked them.
No,
you're exactly right.
That's exactly right.
Several different work.
This is real.
They are paying attention to in Ohio.
Well,
yeah,
that was a really good point that a lot
of people had when trump got elected was
that all these people that live in these
predominantly liberal areas like
California,
New York,
in particular,
New York City in California,
they were all like,
oh my God,
trump is horrible.
Oh my God,
We'd love Hillary.
We're so excited to have our first
female president.
It's going to happen.
It's 100 percent.
Do you know anybody that's voting for
trump?
I don't.
Because they're so insulated.
They literally don't know any
conservative,
so they were convinced that she was
getting exactly right.
If you take out La county in New York
City that like he would have won the
popular vote to just to kind of,
not even the whole state of California,
just La County and like a couple of
bottles of New York City.
He would've won the popular,
but you're right there.
We're in a bubble and what's crazy is
like he's not a good candidate.
It's not like he's like the perfect
Republican and he's not like Reagan
character directly.
Right.
Come upstanding guy who just looked at
him and like,
yeah,
that's a precedent right there.
No,
no.
Which is kind of refreshing.
I mean,
I feel like it.
Yes.
Everybody for the last 30 years.
I don't want to go there,
but you guys know about right wingers.
I'm not fucking.
I'm sure your fans are like this.
Well not.
I'm labeled that.
Are you a right winger or you were like,
oh,
I have a centrist.
I am a Centrus,
but people in show business,
if you lean right on two issues that
have 400,
you're a fucking Nazi.
Had been called a right winger.
Well,
yeah.
I'm pot-smoking Hippie for the minute.
You're a nice blend.
You're not perfect.
You're like fucking Jerry Brown.
When he was what he was saying when he
was saying crazy.
Fuck,
I can't believe he's really the
governor.
Nobody even notices the California
doesn't even need a governor.
Like if he'd died and no one said
anything,
he'd be like,
where's Jerry?
I don't know what you guys want to do.
Let's go eat.
What do you want to do?
You're right.
He doesn't show up much.
He just pops up every once in a while.
Nobody talks about him ever in this
state and he's 71.
He's got to be 70,000
years old.
No one complains about them.
No one talks about them knowing praises
him.
It's just he's a nongovernment when
swartz and edgar was the governor,
everybody talks about,
I can't believe the terminators.
The governor had governor or tee shirts
at the fucking airport you could buy.
I mean it was.
It was a real governor.
Like we knew we had a governor right
now.
You ask the average person just walked
on the street,
who's the governor of California?
They will fucking stare at you like you
have three heads.
They don't even know I liked that.
Well,
it's California.
Gonna succeed from the Union.
What we have to.
We have to.
It's like you might as well.
All those assholes that are using
nonorganic.
What is this?
Where as governor Jerry Brown.
Jerry,
what is this?
Twenty four minutes ago it was put.
There we go.
Perfect.
Governor Jerry Brown's office remains
mom on his location.
Oroville grapples with emergency efforts
can say,
oh,
you heard about that fucking that flood.
The dams ready to blow.
Holy Christ dead.
They're evacuating the area while the
governor.
Hold on a second.
Go back to that.
Sorry.
While the government issued an emergency
order,
Sunday,
there has not been an update since.
His office with was mom on his location.
Oh,
he's fucking dead.
He's dead and they don't want to give a
position that works.
It sounds very Russian.
Remember the Russian leaders,
they all of a sudden you don't hear
about them or scientology when that
guy's wife was missing?
No one talks.
Oh yeah.
And Leah had the balls to ask,
which he was sued.
I had her on the podcast.
I love her.
And like the major she's.
She's a ballsy lady.
Yeah.
She's a little animal.
Very,
very interesting that she was a
scientologist for whole life.
It almost goes contrary to like how she
called bullshit on everything.
Like how the hell did you not call
bullshit on that.
It's weird.
That's my first question.
When I watch that stuff,
I go rally into some office in La and
fucking they gave us some pamphlets and
said,
look,
we can put these on fucking.
How is Catholicism any less ridiculous.
I don't.
I don't believe in that shit.
And I was raised.
Yeah,
I was forced to go to church about
seventh grade and I used to start
wrestling my father,
you know,
breaking shit on Sunday and he wasn't a
religious man.
He was laying in his bed and go,
go to church with your mother.
I think there's a real problem with
having a right in having a left.
I think as soon as you have two sides
that people can pick.
People just get on one side and then
fucking dig their heels in.
Well,
I read that book recently and it's been
out for about 10 years.
You probably are.
I know your boy Alex Jones's mentioned
thousand times in it.
Uh,
the,
you know the truth about the Bilderberg
group,
it was written like 10 years ago.
They keep updating it.
I,
I'll never vote again.
It really is like 40 people running the
whole fucking plant.
Well,
if it really is though,
how the fuck did trump get in?
Because I don't think he wanted him in.
No.
But that sees a part of that.
Yes.
So it's a trick,
but he doesn't know.
He's a part of it.
Oh,
deep.
It runs.
It doesn't swear to God.
Don't you know,
this is the guy's name is Daniel
[inaudible],
e s t u l I N it's about eight,
nine years old.
His book.
And you will fuck I write it on
vacation.
I was,
I was walking around the beach.
I didn't see anything that was in a fog
going.
I can't believe what a sucker I've been
my whole.
I remember I fucking bombed.
And Connecticut and not in Connecticut
and Pennsylvania wants because a buddy
of mine gave me a copy of,
um,
best evidence by David Lipton.
It was a conspiracy,
a book about the assassination by this
Guy David Lifton,
assassination of JFK,
by this guy who was,
he was apparently,
he was an accountant and he was given
some task to write some paper about the,
uh,
the President or about the Warren
Commission and as he was going through
the warrant commission,
which is just this enormous thing,
many,
many volumes.
He found all these inconsistencies and
things didn't make sense and no one
expected everyone to read whatever the
fuck it is,
900 volumes.
So this asshole read at all.
And then he just went into detail about
how ridiculous the Warren Commission
report was.
And then he started investigating the
actual facts behind the assassination
itself.
It freaked me the fuck out.
I was like,
they killed the president of man.
You went on stage,
right?
I'm at it.
I've done nothing.
Nothing's funny.
Eight deck.
I've done that a couple times.
God,
goddammit.
Well,
I did when I was living in La,
I read Robert Bork,
Judge Barker,
and it to me it crystallized a lot of
shit that I was thinking that I go,
oh my God,
all this history and,
but I was living in La at the time and
I'm trying to spew some of that shit
like it lawyer companies can do.
That probably is a little bit more
exactly.
But as the military,
the original room at the comedy store,
they weren't really having some lady got
so fucking mad at me at the original
room where I was just saying that I
don't think that women should be able to
guard the White House.
You know,
that bit that I had and the bit was that
I can guard the White House either.
You know how I know because I met
Shaquille O'neal in his Dick is where my
face is.
I'm like,
well the White House is experiencing a
Shaq attack.
I'm the wrong dude to save the world.
Like people are not fucking even.
We're not even.
And then the joke and she was fucking
screaming and yelling at me and go,
listen,
stupid.
I just said,
I can't do it either.
I the do.
Do you understand that?
Now?
They don't hear that part.
They hear the part.
You said women shouldn't.
Exactly.
That's all they glom onto.
I'm like.
Then I said,
look,
this is where she gets really crazy and
I wound up having to kick her out and I
go,
my favorite people in the world where
all women.
I have a wife,
I have three daughters.
They're my favorite people in the planet
guy,
but I can beat the fuck out of all of
them and she went crazy.
She was like,
that's what I can't line it up,
set it up,
set it up and put the house on me.
What you just crystallize there?
I've been going through for like 30
years on staff.
It's so crazy.
It's just.
But I'm saying myself,
I'm like,
I feel with physical combat on a daily
basis almost.
I know what you can and can't do.
You can't leave a girl guarding the
fucking White House by yourself unless
you have that bitch in a robo cop suit
with fucking nuclear weapons.
She's not going to pull it off.
I said,
well,
one of my bits was talking about women
in the military.
This was again,
I think I was living in la when I wrote
that.
I don't think they should be in the
middle of die because they don't throw
that.
Well,
I don't,
I don't think I go,
I don't think you should die because
Pam's grenade landed a flip from the
bumper and it's one of my best,
you know,
I did it on Letterman.
That's fun.
I made and,
but uh,
every time there'll be a table at girls
that would get the feathers.
Well,
I'm not black.
I'm not happy that Ronda Rousey lost.
But in a way it makes things easier
because there was a bunch of fucking
people that were going,
oh yeah.
What about Ronda Rousey?
She'll kick it.
And I made the mistake of saying like
hyperbole.
Okay,
I'm the master of hyperbole.
I've exaggerated all the time.
I was like,
she could probably beat half the men
bantamweights and true.
No,
it's not true.
I shouldn't have said it at the time.
Now.
It's definitely not true.
She could beat a few that aren't good
outside the sport.
Look,
if she gets guys in the ground,
she can fuck a lot of people up or judo
is 100 percent legit.
Her arm bars are amongst the best in the
business,
but we're always saying that bank debt
to me,
she'll flip your,
your head.
You're fucked.
I'm fucked.
I'm kidding.
I fuck you up.
But the point is even with some coconut
oil or all these fucking.
We were like,
what about Ronda Rousey Ronda,
right.
Okay.
And then thank God.
Now that she's lost,
everyone's relaxed with that,
but then the argument is,
well,
who she lost to.
You know who,
who fucked her up the most lesbian.
I mean.
Yeah.
No,
that's exactly right.
Here's the thing with the feminist
movement,
they used to,
you know,
we can do anything men can do,
but they wouldn't push the physical
thing they did,
but not anymore.
No.
I was at Gotham comedy club about three
years ago and I'm doing a fight.
Breaks out,
had nothing to do with me.
Two tables got into it.
I mean a big.
There's a woman in the middle standing
in the middle,
a girl,
and I don't mean like a butch dykey like
a brunch.
She's thinks that she can.
She's got her hands up,
she throws a punch at one of the door
man or woman comes over and knocks her
out.
Like she was fucking Larry Holmes in his
sixties.
She went down like she was shot and uh,
I never heard any lawsuits or anything,
but she was throwing haymakers at that,
like the fucking door.
They really believe.
And again,
like you said,
Amanda Nunez,
I'd be scared of that broad.
But,
uh,
Amanda Nunez and knock a lot of dudes
out.
Yeah,
that's it.
I mean Ken Lesbian.
But it could be something there.
Well,
yeah,
she's half a guy,
you know,
that was an interesting to just fine.
Well,
I eat,
she's not,
she's all,
she's all woman.
She's a woman,
but you don't think some of her.
She's got a little more in a less
estrogen than my wife.
A little,
little more man.
Joe.
I think it's all by saying that I'm not
being derogatory and I made.
Yeah,
I think she should be more celebrated
than she is because she's the first ever
woman of lesbian champion in mma.
I mean there's,
you don't see how come lesbians get
their own designation.
Like they're not just gay,
like it's lbg,
you know what I mean?
Lesbian,
lesbian and gay.
Like they get their own thing.
They're not just gay,
but you can't be a gay woman.
You're also a lesbian.
Like a gay man is not a thing.
Like he doesn't have an extra thing.
It's not like you're also a lesbian,
you know,
you're,
you know what I mean?
Now you're talking to Tom Cruise,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
lesbians are not just gay.
They have their own little designation.
That's how they want it.
They get what they want.
This I was reading,
I was reading those.
Joey,
I was reading those,
uh,
like the terms now.
CISGENDER.
Oh yeah,
those are wonderful.
I ran out,
I ran out of printing paper.
I'm not shitting.
I would spit out was,
I was on like page 78.
I ran out of paper and I just started
reading them.
I actually do this in my special,
my CSO special that's coming out
Thursday.
I was talking about like what's so
confusing now,
the libs,
you confuse every and nobody knows what
bathroom to use and I got out at a night
club the other night and here's the
ladies room right here,
and the men's room is right.
Next one's a pile of shit in the middle
with a Tampon.
Stuck it in effect mustache.
It's true and I'm not being derogatory.
I actually have a relative who's like
transgender.
I wouldn't want to fucking have the dea,
you know,
but,
but we're talking about these people,
like they make up 60 percent of the
population.
That's where I get a little fucking
angry.
Well,
who's that guy from road has been the
guy with the mustache that talks like
this.
You know that guy.
I was always in La.
Trust Sam Elliot,
Sam Elliot.
Yes.
There's a great meme with Sam Elliott
and it was like they used to be a time
where we worried more about the safety
of women and children than men who like
to wear dresses.
It was one of those memes online.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
and someone put it up and everybody went
crazy because here's the thing,
like there are people who are fucking
crazy,
who are men who liked to wear dresses,
want to pretend they're a woman.
There's transgender people and then
there's sick fucks that also likes to
wear dresses or go into the women's
room.
Opened the door.
You open the door to everybody.
Well,
that's it.
I said to these young kids and I'm
onstage like these kids in their
twenties,
like you should be taken advantage of
this confusion.
You had a nightclub,
you see a hot chick.
You just slap it on and follow her into
the ladies room and go.
I identify as a dyke tonight.
Open that I'm Annie Lennox went back
when she used to wear suits,
but I'm definitely a woman.
Any Linux used to wear suits,
sweet dreams are made of and I don't
remember what.
But when,
when,
when.
That was big.
When we looking at it going,
Whoa,
what will.
Sexuality is good and it's super hot.
Everything.
Beautiful shoes.
So did she come up there?
She is.
No,
she's a woman.
She's a woman.
She actually looks good there for crisis
with orange hair.
Fuck Bush.
That looks like if trump was transgender
in his teens,
not even as teens.
Like what?
He's like 11.
It looks like the president.
What a weird haircut.
Look at that.
He's got to let his hair go.
I want to talk to him.
I want to get him on mushrooms.
Get them shave his head toe.
Trump can change a lot.
He should let it go.
Gray.
He's not just great like what the fuck
is going on?
I don't know is there's so much stuff
happening in his head while he's got a
trim around the years.
This isn't 19,
75.
I'm just saying,
but I think he's picky.
He likes keeping it long so he could
fucking spin it around and cover all the
barren lands.
Well,
that's true.
You can hide a lot of deficiencies.
He's definitely got something going on.
There's a whole theory as to what's
happening in his hair that there was a.
There was a guy that ran a company that
will.
They would take hair and they would buy
hair from like people in India and then
they bleach it to whatever color your
hair is and then they would attach it to
your skull,
these micro filaments,
and it's kind of get that done.
Well,
it looked like shit and they went out of
business except they had an office in
trump tower right below below trump's
office and so the company went out of
business,
but the office still remains.
So the idea is that he's the only client
and trump comes down,
gets his hair done by this guy who was
in like,
I don't want to.
That's a great
idea.
I want to say it was like esquire or Gq,
like one of those magazines and it was
like the secret behind trump's hair.
There's this whole investigative report
on trump's hair.
It sounds like a plot for CBS Sitcom,
you know?
Did you see what was going on?
And I think it was chilly.
There was a paper,
a newspaper that had a photo of trump or
they use the Alec Baldwin picture
instead of the Donald trump picked.
They fucked up or they did it on
purpose.
He did it on purpose.
NBC will be doing that gun we fucked up.
Yeah,
right.
Here it is.
This is what the guy used to do the
micro cylinder.
So it's like these little things that
glue to your hair.
So it looks like the hairs are coming
straight out of your scalp because they
glue these little like little tiny hula
hoops with hair attached to it I guess.
And it sticks right out of your hair
right out of your head.
Yeah,
I don't totally understand it.
It's probably like pubes from a third
world country.
Apparently it looked like shit.
Which makes sense because his hair looks
like shit.
Right.
Look at that.
See 500 here is added in 90 minutes.
He's got this thing going around his
hair.
See that?
I mean that is like trump's hair.
That is.
Yes.
So this guy was bald and now he's got
this flop that.
There it is.
See that's a wave in Hawaii.
Somebody should be writing like it does.
His hair doesn't make any sense.
It's like there's so much volume,
but so little volume at the same time.
Well,
when.
Yeah,
when you 70,
it shouldn't be long in the back.
Well all of it should.
It's chaos.
Like why not just shave your fucking
head bro?
It's so easy.
You're,
you're worth a fucking $100,000,000,000.
You or your wife has not down with you
because of the way you look.
You know,
like shave your fucking head.
You can do whatever you want,
but when you're that age and you got
that much here,
you don't want to shave it.
Like you look good for the ballpark.
I feel good.
I'm not just kissing your ass,
but you do.
Uh,
but he,
I mean he,
something tells me he's got a big veiny
giant scared the shit out of both
Republicans and Democrats who had like
an Ogres Dick.
I don't know what that looks like.
Just veiny and angry.
Big Slot and magically find.
I really was a dickhead.
Like he's got a whole,
like a whale whole top of his head and
she just pre comes Lincoln out.
Holy Shit.
Cover it,
cover it on the plane.
On the way to Chicago,
I opened the airplane magazine because I
fucking forgot to bring my shit,
so I'm reading that and his Joe Rogan
front and center talking about
Valentine's Day.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That was saying I wrote something that
was so outrageous,
but it was really good.
Well,
what they would put in there,
it was like a fraction of what I wrote.
What I wrote was filled with swear words
and not mine.
You have,
you would just let Leo female side show
with a little.
My female side is all they left in the
stuff.
I,
he,
the guy asked me to write something.
I'm like,
all right,
so I'm going to give a fuck.
So I smoked a joint and I wrote
something crazy and uh,
Sarah to them and they're like,
well they have to edit it heavily.
I'm like,
let him who cares?
And so what's in there?
It's like barely mine,
but it made sense.
It was kind of.
I was like,
oh my God,
he's.
Because you said like in a few years
what the grasp of the whole article was
you saying let it go.
Let it out.
It's like you love your wife,
write it in a car and stuff.
Let that shit out.
Because in a few years we're going to be
able to read each other's minds.
Right?
Wasn't that the justice and it made
sense and I usually don't believe in
that shit.
I'm like,
Ooh,
we're.
We're about 30 years away from being
mind reading robots.
I really believe that.
I don't think we've got to be done that,
so I don't give a fuck.
I think we're gonna we're going to be
some sort of a combination of people and
machine within the next 30 years.
I really do.
I don't.
I think if you think about how close we
are with communication about how we can
tweet and send pictures and share
information so quickly,
almost instantaneously,
then the next possible step is that
we're going to be closer than that and
we're going to have that shit in your
head and we're going to make a chip that
has.
So I think so they were already doing or
not.
They've some probably.
I know the audience I played in Chicago
that seemed like they had chips.
I'm like,
you know,
it was great,
you have to do that in Chicago,
but this Rosemont great,
unbelievable ideas.
Just did as a CSO special there.
Yeah,
that's what they told me.
Room,
great room.
She goes to me,
she goes,
but she even want me.
He goes,
the Saturday crowd.
I sold out three of the four,
or should I was excited about it.
She goes to Saturday early shelf.
Might be they get a little rowdy.
I'm on stage five minutes.
I'm making fun of Hilary.
You know,
they got mad at you.
I'm like,
no,
just one fat,
ugly bitch.
Got Mad at.
I wanted to kick her fucking ugly.
Head off her shoulders.
This chubbies fucking miserable.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm going.
Yeah,
I could tell them,
you know,
Hillary wasn't healthy.
I can tell you shit stain in her pants
suit.
She's going up the stairs,
his blood come out of the nostrils.
Earwax and,
and she goes,
this lady right up front.
It's because you're a fucking asshole.
And it gives me the finger.
Whoa.
Like,
and,
and you know,
it's her hero,
Bro.
Why don't you be nice to her hero?
Fuck her heroine,
fuck her,
because a new picture of Hillary and
bill and Hillary bills looks like he's
wearing something from a motorcycle
movie from the 19 seventies and Hillary
is dressed like the villain and every
Kung Fu movie,
and I'm not kidding.
She's literally wearing a fucking car.
I've joked around about that before that
she dresses like the villain in every
comfortable,
but let's get to the next level and she
literally has like an Asian jacket on
and some fucking scarf underneath it.
She's trying to cover up the Turkey neck
because she loves China.
It's her version of a comb over.
She's just going to the miles from that.
How shall I saw her on the woods the
other day?
She's like,
yeah,
and he lived four miles from their
house.
They have a house in the day,
have a house in Chappaqua.
These are really up at Westchester.
I'm flaky.
They probably have 100 houses was
crooks.
They would make so much money being
civil servants.
Well,
they didn't dig once they get out.
even when they were in.
Well,
well W,
I mean he was given the majority of it
when they started that foundation.
We know how they made it.
I'm in the selling influence all over
the world.
Foundation just took a big hit.
Something just happened with that
foundation.
Oh yeah,
they're going to shut it down.
There's no exposed during the election
that it was a.
There was a big article like very
recently.
I didn't read it.
I saw someone was telling me about it.
I don't know what it is,
shop talking,
but I walk into podcasts.
I fly when I'm like,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
That's where I step on the gas when I
dig my heels and start fucking swearing.
Yeah.
How about that picture I sent you
yesterday that I pull it to Duke
Fitzsimmons podcasts.
Clinton foundation partner hiked opiod
overdose,
hiked opiod overdose reversal drug price
by 90 percent.
That's very republican of Jesus Christ.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah,
so an opiod overdose reversal drug which
saves people from opiate and they hiked
the price.
It's opioid.
Am I saying it wrong?
I say opioid,
right?
I'm saying it wrong.
Opioid refers overdose.
We're fruit,
it shouldn't be a word like that.
Opioid,
it's heroin.
It's fucking heroin to say,
we'll call it horse overdose reversal
drug by 680 percent.
Oh,
I'm sure that we have the testaments.
We have dual side is far.
Stockholders are important,
but I support Hillary Clinton and women
that I support.
A woman's right to choose a woman's
right to choose.
It's very important.
How many times have you heard the word,
the phrase a strong woman in the last
fucking 20 years old,
nasty women.
Everyone's a nasty woman.
Now,
remember that when?
When trump called her nasty woman,
then all of a sudden all of these women
had nasty woman as their twitter handle.
Yes.
You Jen Kirkman.
She called her self Gen Kurt Nasty.
Kirk woman.
She wasn't cooking anymore.
They're having fun with it,
I guess,
and went nuts when that tape.
I'm about.
Trump loves to grab pussy.
So does Hillary.
Why is it controversial?
Does or what you think it's saying?
Are you trying to say that?
Are you kidding me?
She burped in my face once.
Cvs.
Oh,
like a three.
All macro.
Like a candidate.
Small muscles in the back of the minivan
for three weeks in August.
I like smoked oysters.
Oh,
I don't know.
I'm not going to think about them now.
When I open them up.
I'm gonna.
Think of Hillary's breath.
You'll think a clit so when you open.
He's really.
Yeah,
it looks like a mutilated clitoris
because there are a good way of
maintaining a ketogenic diet.
Nick Depaulo not because I'm
disparaging.
I know about all that shit.
I saw you eating.
You put up those little videos.
I know it was a facebook live or
whatever.
You will make them breakfast with like
five eggs and Kimchi and shit.
I went and I.
I have like four or five eggs every
month.
I lawyer those goddamn criminals
probably that worked for the Clinton
administration.
They were trying to convince us for a
long time that eggs are bad for you.
That cholesterol does.
Listen to me folks.
Not Bad.
Very good for you.
I saw you had like Kimchi and it was
enough.
It looked like good.
Last you.
Two weeks.
Let's [inaudible] you hypostome oh
right.
I'm still hyper.
God dammit.
I have this right here,
you need a workout while I'm talking to
people and I want to try that elk Ross
get made.
I was hoping you had some leftovers.
My,
my buddy John Dudley had this guy,
Chad board on his podcast and Chad Ward
is this a barbecue master and he was
basically saying that we're,
when I cook that what I'm doing by
grilling things over high heat that you
fuck it up because you dry out the meat
somewhat.
So it was like,
all right,
well what does he say to do?
It says don't cook anything over 275
degrees.
I'm like,
all right,
I'll try it.
So I put an elk roast on last night.
I put a meat thermometer in that bitch
and I love it in slow,
low and slow for like an hour and a
half.
I cooked this roast and it wasn't a big
roast either.
Cook different hour and a half.
Got It to 125 degrees.
Then I took up frying pan and you said
the south side?
Yeah,
with with butter.
Hot butter,
butter.
You wrap it up in aluminum foil and you
put it in a cooler because the cooler
will keep it warm.
Just like it keeps it cold.
Right?
I put it in a Yeti cooler.
No Shit.
Yeah.
This is what the.
All those barbecue masters do.
They let it finish in a cooler and then
I pulled that bitch out.
I sliced it up.
Holy Shit.
I was looking at the pictures.
It was cooked.
Holy Shit.
Was He right?
It was so delicious and it was so much
moister than any row.
I'd cook some delicious rose in the
past,
but they were always a good cook.
I've been told that I can cut into it
too soon and that's why there's all that
bleeding out.
A teenager was amazing.
I poured that blood all over it.
I enjoyed that behind you.
Okay.
What's on the outside of it?
Go.
What's the rub?
Not to turn this into kosher salt.
Kosher salt,
black pepper and garlic powder.
So I put all that on before I put it.
Excuse me,
before I put it into the grill,
before I put it into the pellet grill
pellet grills.
If you don't have one of those,
I don't.
They have a pellet gun.
Oh,
do you?
Yeah,
she'd squirrels and shit.
Yes.
Pellet grills are the shit because they,
they maintain the same temperature and
it's all run on wood because it's.
It's totally healthy because they have
an element like a heating element in
there and they have these wood pellets
in the wood.
Pellets are made when they cut wood for
a table like this,
they take the hardwood from that stuff
and then decompress it and then natural
sugars in the would allow it to stay in
these pellets and the pellets.
You can break them up in your hand.
It's not like they're like really easy
to break because they're not really
solid,
but when the heating element cooks them,
then the heat from that and the fire
from the pellets and the smoke flavors.
The meat.
So it's natural wood flavor and 100
percent natural.
No Chemicals.
You can get flavored pellets,
you mean?
Yeah,
you can get.
No,
you can get apple,
applewood,
you can get oak,
you can get hickory.
I don't think they have posted,
but you can probably start it.
You could probably start your own
company.
Yeah.
Just have a bunch of girls sit in there
by the lumberyard.
Just take it rubbing on the snatch that.
No,
that looked.
I saw that.
I'm like,
Dad,
that is cooked perfectly well.
Nice crunch on the outside to guys.
Definitely.
Right.
Because before I was doing it all by eye
and doing it by timing,
but using a meat thermometer.
I got the inside to 125 degrees this
which is not quite enough.
It's a little low then cooking.
Yeah,
exactly.
So then when you sear it on the outside
it gets a little more inside because of
that.
And then when you wrap it up in aluminum
foil because a searing it was only a few
minutes and then you see her at the end,
which is just the opposite.
What people used to do the outside,
well this guy's a world champion
barbecue guy,
so I just listened to him,
you know,
but I don't know ma'am.
They do it differently at certain
steakhouses that state councilors you're
cooking a beef,
beef steak and a beef steak is so filled
with fat.
It's so different now.
Now the,
uh,
elk,
is it lean,
super lean,
punch back.
Oh,
it's the most flavorful.
Usually isn't.
That's why people eat beef.
It's got a rich different kind of taste
to it because it's just,
it's such a healthy animal because that
it's a giant fucking animal and it's out
there running around eating whatever the
fuck it wants.
It's not,
it's not a,
it's not at this seven,
11 and midnight.
It's like you're eating an athlete,
you know,
it's like you're going to lose his ass.
It's like you got something that can run
and sprint Tyson me joke.
Just to bring you back from the Ed.
Is that what it said on the menu when
you started salivating?
Thinking about Carla was bent over a
sofa?
No,
after I ran a three fucking charity.
Poland his ass apart days.
Good luck.
Herschel Walker.
Yeah.
It would have been better.
No,
that's um,
but you're getting,
you're getting like this is healthy,
strong animal.
It just has more vitamins in it,
more nutrients.
It tastes different.
It's just got.
It's more vibrant unless I fucking
killed it,
so I know where it came from.
I was there.
When you hit it on the one on one,
it's not shot with a bow and Arrow,
so that was my cousin.
He said,
fucking cousin,
cousins of killer.
Not a bow and Arrow guy.
It's to me it's like,
I dunno man.
Maybe it's not for everybody.
You went to Englewood.
I went to watts.
I found it outside of a liquor store at
3:00
in the morning.
Bugling where'd you go?
Hunt and seriously,
but elk.
That one,
I think that was from a honed ranch,
which is not honestly not that far from
here.
He was on a ranch and was pen then
that's not pending at all.
Two hundred 70,000
acres.
Free Range.
We're here notes.
It's upstate.
It's like outside of like a half hour
outside of Bakersfield.
Yeah.
It's a huge ranch.
The biggest ranch and all California and
so I've been there.
I've hunted elk there.
I've got a deer that I shot in Iowa that
I'm going to cook that way tonight.
Yeah.
My cousin,
that's what he does.
Boeing arrows.
The way to go.
It just takes way too long to learn how
to do it for most people,
but it does not loud,
you know,
like there's no,
like this is my friend Cameron hanes
always likes to describe it.
He's like,
when you go to the woods,
like everything is peaceful and quiet
and the guns like boom.
He's like,
you don't
seem out of place to go.
What the fuck?
He's like,
but with a bow and Arrow,
it's like almost silence,
like black,
you know,
but it just takes off and it's harder.
It's much a sport.
When you got a little more even,
you got to get closer.
You got to get way closer.
Are you going to be like sitting on its
back when you got to be fucking sneaky?
Because that's,
that's what's really exciting about like
when you're stocking,
like one of the most fun hunts I went
on,
I was,
I failed.
I went to Nevada,
we went a spot and stalk hunting for
mule deer,
and so you're like,
you're creeping up on these deer and
these fucking deer.
A mule deer is one of the largest deer
species and it lives in mostly in the
west.
And um,
they,
uh,
that's a mule deer right there.
And that's a mule deer right there.
That one with the velvet stone.
It's a big deer and they live in the
woods and you got to creep up on these
fuckers because they're used to being
attacked by mountain lions.
So like,
here's a huge,
like a mules ear.
That's why they call them mule deer and
see how big their fucking years.
I'm like,
Hey,
what's going on?
Because Obama,
what's over here?
What's over here?
How dare you fucking big ears you and
not an Obama Fan.
I'm a a Bama fan as a statesman.
I don't think a lot of things.
He did a very good point,
but as a statesman think he was an
excellent representative.
I buy that.
That's part of the problem with trump is
that now assholes have a king.
You know?
It's like usually there so that.
But see,
that's what Allah.
He's,
he's plain spoken.
That's what I like about him.
He's not a fucking professional
politician and know that's sort of what
I like about him.
He's not a professional message and
don't get me wrong,
but what do you.
What do you like about him?
What do you like about the farm?
Yes,
I did.
Oh,
how dare you.
They're not going to let you leave.
Huh?
Jerry Brown's going to raise up funds.
Going fucking smoking dope or not bad
for you.
How dare you?
I forgot what I'm talking to.
What show I was.
See,
that's why I confused because I have
guns in.
We'd.
Yeah,
I like the two of them together.
The Great.
Don't be scared.
What did you do?
I told you my story.
I did.
I.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Well,
edibles are a different trip,
especially for a guy wouldn't have
joined since 1992.
She start super slow and acid put me
fucking freaked out.
We were on vacation recently and my wife
can put away the fucking animals.
She likes edibles.
She likes to eat adult before she goes
to bed and our friend of ours,
who is a guy from England,
really great guy,
very smart guy,
doesn't speak French and doesn't smoke
the pot at all.
And my wife was like,
I'm going to,
I'm going to take my medicine.
And she,
she takes,
she takes it before she goes to bed.
She likes it,
it relaxes her.
And he's like,
well,
you know what was that every night like
every night and not sleep without it.
If she doesn't have,
she gets to leave without it.
She sleeps better with it,
but she,
she goes down,
me and she fucking,
she,
she doesn't get Joey Diaz doses but she
takes high doses.
So anyway,
um,
she gives some to our friend and uh,
she gives him half of what she takes,
like,
oh,
that's too much.
She's like,
oh,
he's going to be fine.
This motherfucker,
like an hour and a half later it was
like we have to check on the children
and make sure they're still breathing
mine.
And next day he was still high.
The next day woke up for breakfast,
still high.
Just tripping his balls off because when
you eat it,
it's a psychedelic drug.
It's not the same thing.
Fuck.
And first of all,
like I said,
literally I hadn't smoked a joint.
I wasn't ever a weed guy since like the
early nineties.
So just weed in general is stronger and
then to make it an edible.
And then I did the typical rookie stupid
thing.
I took a corner of it and I waited about
31 minutes.
I'm like,
this ain't doing shit exactly that.
I ate the rest,
like a snickers bar.
Next thing.
And I'm like,
fucking those are the four words.
No,
never say after you take weed.
I don't feel shit.
It was my first word yourself up for
disaster.
I had no idea.
You know,
I didn't eat the whole thing,
but I took another bite and then I'm
watching my fucking,
like I said,
my flat screen TV 51 inch and then all
of a sudden it looked like a black and
white 11 inch TV.
You start freaking and it sounded a mile
away and she had.
So I did what you supposed to do in that
situation.
I ran into a dark bedroom in standard
alarm clock.
Well,
you know what,
you should do fucked up like that.
Drink coffee.
That's one thing.
The coffee does counteract the,
uh,
the cannabis.
That's one thing to do.
If you ever really freaking out.
If you have too much pot,
your system,
drink coffee.
Another one,
take a cold shower.
Who's getting them cold as fuck?
Just get in there and suffered where you
can't breathe.
You know those cold showers?
Are you clothed?
She's just.
No,
I don't.
I love those showers.
I'd take those showers all the time.
Especially after yoga.
I take a hot yoga and then I take a cold
shower.
Like funny it goes.
It gets.
If you're wide awake.
If I could put ice in the water tank,
I would do that.
It's just like,
whew.
Mysterious illness linked to marijuana
use and the rise and legal weed states
that Scott Adams,
what they do to him.
You've got younger.
This story was going around for a couple
of weeks ago.
Why does it at the end of the year,
it's called a.
it's called it's killing causes damage.
Cannabinoid.
Hyper Misa Syndrome.
Is it real?
Oh,
I had no way you can look up on it.
People went to the Er for it,
but we have this nausea,
vomiting and crampy abdominal pain.
Walking off pussy hot showers or baths.
Interesting.
Relieved by hot showers.
Okay.
Maybe I'm giving the wrong advice.
Just take a hot shower.
Oh,
I'm saying cold.
Thanks.
Jeff.
Declamation pussy.
You know why it says hot shower?
Because you're too much of a pussy to
take a cold shower.
A cold shower.
Probably qg quicker.
Uh,
I love cold showers because it's like
it's suffering.
You have to suffer there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was when I lived in a fraternity,
university of Maine,
a hot water heater broke down.
It's,
it's,
yeah,
February main.
Okay.
Let her literally minus 21 outside and
we didn't have.
I go in the shower and it's so called.
You could feel each individual drop
hitting you on the head.
Like it hurt.
It was made my eyes.
Water.
It's fucking like almost 32 degrees.
Exactly.
Just a shade over ice when I was doing
back in the top window days,
there's this guy named Bob Rella and he
was.
My instructor is one of my instructors,
first black belts and it was just a
complete psycho and Bob Calf Rela you
said always take cold showers.
That's what he said.
He slept in the gym.
He lived in the gym.
He said teach classes there for the
longest time and he would take cold
showers because it was good for the
spirit.
This guy didn't take a quick shower
either.
It wasn't like,
okay,
we're done.
No,
they're just sitting there and we would
all be terrified of him and we get in
that cold shower.
We knew how cold it was and it was like
a different level of psycho.
He was.
It's a horrible way to die.
You don't die that way.
You just get cold.
Nondisabled people have fallen through
ice and.
Oh yeah,
and I mean,
can you imagine there's a photo that
they found recently of a moose.
It was like half in,
half out.
It just got tired trying to get out of
the ice and [inaudible] moves a walk on
frozen lakes,
but no,
they're fucking 1800 pounds and then
they'll step in one area where it's not
that thick.
This fucker went right through and you
just got stuck
any and they froze.
Their froze there in the lake.
Like that lady in the news last week.
The goodwill bin.
You read that one right?
In some way?
I think it was in Pennsylvania.
She goes to a goodwill bin to put it in.
Yeah,
at two in the morning.
Although they said she had items out
when they found her,
it sounded like she was robin it to me,
but she's in the goodwill bank tone.
The morning the fuck,
and she's on a foot ladder.
Know the band lead,
falls in on her arm.
Her arm and wrist.
She's hanging from the side of the band.
The latter.
She's caught there listening to this.
That happened at two in the morning.
They find were frozen to death.
The next one.
Oh Jesus.
Not fucking whore.
She's doing a nice thing.
Contributing close.
Talk about it.
No good deed and they find her hanging
from the bins
people do that.
They don't realize how risky it is.
Like you ever see someone trying to fix
their gutter with a ladder.
And that was my old man.
I can't.
That's how well already lane's dad fell
off her eyes.
Yeah,
I'm fucking ladders.
My old man will be on a ladder with
fucking like a cigarette work and
there'll be a gas pipe of floataway know
Christ like data.
The guy from Osha wants to talk to you.
I was at a gas station recently in
Hollywood and some asshole came up to
me,
asked me about my car and he's smoking a
cigarette and the guy who run the gas
station screaming at him,
get the fuck away from the gas,
get the fuck away from the guest.
And he's like,
fuck you bitch.
He was like,
this weird guy was just hanging out
wearing black and I wasn't black.
That was weird.
He was like pretending the Indian guy I
think you know good though.
Fuck.
He was.
It was so caricature because he was like
a caricature of an Indian gas station
owner.
But he really wasn't actually in India
there's a gas station that I go to is
run by Indians and they even have like a
fucking old sign on the door.
It's like the peaceful gas station
because the nicest people,
they're all Indians at work.
They're super cool.
Sometimes it'll be a table,
like when I'm doing a show and they
hanging on
every word polite and I point everybody
else.
Why can't you be like the let's say to
the rest of the audience,
look at this Indian table with manners
and Indians in general are very
interesting people because they have a
caste system that they don't.
They just,
they have rich people,
like extremely rich people that exist
with extremely poor people with no
problems.
It's real weird.
Like they had.
There's a,
there's a man that's the key to the is
that the key is,
oh,
so there's too much integration there.
There's,
there's a,
there's this extremely wealthy guy in
India and he has this fucking palace and
surrounding his palaces,
like utter slums and ghetto.
And he's got a golden palace and his
name is Aziz Ansari.
Trussell.
Peter's ladies and gentleman.
Oh,
Russell P,
I forgot there's a bigger guy.
Yeah,
he's the biggest.
Russell Russell's the biggest Indian.
Well,
he's one of the biggest comedians in the
world.
He's also one of the biggest nice guy.
He is a sweetheart dust at the festival.
He takes us all to a blue,
a blue jays game and throw out the first
pitch or some shit.
Yeah,
he slept in a bed.
Nicer man.
Russell Peters is live in the goddamn
dream.
Really is.
He's one of the greatest guys I've ever
met in my life.
I love him and I really,
I don't know Aziz.
I see.
I used to see him at the comedy cellar,
but I don't.
He's a fan.
That impression.
I'm left wing.
I have zero problem with them.
I've always said hi to him.
I always got along with them,
but other people have issues with them,
but I never know what that issue is
hard.
You know when someone has issues with
someone,
you're like,
okay,
are you jealous?
Are you a dick?
Do you think that he deserved.
It's always,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to tell because the knock on
some people are the like,
like someone said this to me and I
don't,
I don't agree with it,
but this is what they said.
They were like,
you know,
all the only reason why he's as famous
at all.
It's because he's Indian.
He's not funny.
No.
I was like,
well that camp,
that doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
That doesn't make any sense.
So I,
he,
I know he's a fucking hard hard worker
because I played up at Albany and I was
talking to Tommy Nikki because name that
runs into Albany club and he told me is
he came up,
he was tightening up but like an arena,
you know,
and he did and one night he did a 5:45
minute sets.
I believe it's five.
We worked together at the comedy store,
which,
and he some point I did three shows in a
row back to back three shows in a row
and he's got his notes out and he's
working on material follow anybody.
Yeah.
Good for him at this thing that happens
when someone becomes famous where
instead of people like if you don't,
even if you don't get it,
there's a lot of people that I don't
get.
I don't think they're famous,
but I don't talk shit about.
No,
I don't care.
After Bay when we were younger,
like I'm much better now when you're
younger,
when you get into the business,
you're like,
why is he making it?
I'm not putting back.
Then when you see how hard it is and you
got to put the work in regard this,
like you said in this context,
you might not like what they do and as
you get older you can appreciate what it
took to.
Of course,
right?
Yeah.
Speaking of that,
let me ask you,
but probably do you have those
going on and I'm like,
ah.
I'm like Bernie Sanders.
He's writing a letter we have to deal
with.
It's called incoming equality and come
to greg.
That was in the bathroom.
I saw hillary's balls.
She's got a big bulky black lives matter
and yeah,
I tried to help them with that.
That's why he lost.
He couldn't get the black vote.
I said,
change your first name to colonel.
What the fuck?
It's right in front of you.
Nothing here and fucking a fucking
woodland hills China that you're talking
about.
Delicious food and that's racist.
Is that chilled?
Does this show that big where you have
to worry about offending sponsors?
Meet in my basement by myself saying
answers are fine.
Don't worry.
They've seen it all by now.
It's not a fucking single thing we could
throw at them,
although match.com
it.
They were one and done with me.
I was like,
c'mon.
Everybody wants to fuck.
Cut.
Cut me off after one ad to people like
chlamydia.
I'm like,
look,
everybody who doesn't like to fuck?
Am I lying?
I'm trying to get you guys some money.
Who doesn't?
I'm 50.
You don't like to fund anymore place.
I got the hips of fucking 70 year old
soccer player whom we can get you to
yoga class.
Get you some fucking kettlebells toward
doing some swings before.
Let me again.
Do you know George Lopez?
Yes.
Never met him.
Fucking love him.
Yeah.
Love is comedy.
I just,
I can't believe I haven't run into him
somewhere he could.
Dude,
I know.
He seems like he called me up after the
Carl's been CEO thing.
This is his first words out of his
mouth.
My motherfucker.
I know I would like.
I,
I look,
I know he's not crazy about yet,
but he does it.
So funny.
Going half towels,
soft,
white people are in shit.
He's,
he's,
he's a true to me.
Fun Comic Man.
It makes me laugh.
I'm a funny guy offstage.
He's a comic jam and I never fucking met
him.
I just,
I,
I thought I'd run into him somewhere,
but I guess it's not surprising at them.
You'd love them.
Why am I going to see that thing where
he got in trouble?
Yeah.
What?
Chewing out the girl.
Me Every night for the last 40 years now
he said,
well,
what he said was funny.
He says,
he goes,
Latinos,
we have two rules.
Don't park it from my house and don't
marry a black guy.
I mean he's just being funny and some
lady stands up and starts yelling at
him.
Black.
I don't know.
I don't know,
they wouldn't mention it on TMZ.
You might want to put that in the
fucking article it.
So she bought this store.
Couldn't tell.
I'm saying yes.
You think so?
Yeah.
Maybe she was one of my hand Jack
couldn't be.
She's like enough,
but no,
you're right.
It could be a white lid,
but I'm guessing I was just guessing
that the way he said it and shit.
But,
but it's not going to hurt his career.
No,
it's going to help his career.
But you would get more trouble.
Like when Tracy Morgan said if I have a
baby and was gay,
I'd kill it.
Oh,
that bed.
Even though he said I stabbed a little
Nigga.
Oh,
that's different.
Matter of fact in have pass.
I thought he used the word kill but
stab.
But he's,
he's fucking hilarious.
But my point being he,
he got,
he got a little hot water for about a
day and a half.
Well he actually had to apologize.
He
apologized.
Fine.
But,
but if that was you or somebody at your
level of fame and you're white,
you're poly Dourdan matter,
you'd be fucking booted.
Yeah,
I guess so man.
I just,
I feel like you know,
so there has to be a line where you
realize that someone is just fucking
around.
There has to be aligned with whatever
happened to just fucking around.
If you want to kill just brian and his
fucking followers.
I'm not asking them anyway.
Nobody knows where he is.
He's dead.
He's hiding under the.
He's underneath the fucking.
Hey,
I'm trying to fix it with crazy glue.
That's true.
Nobody has seen him lately.
Is that currently?
He's old as fuck,
man.
When you that old,
you're going to have some days where you
can't go outside for days.
Right?
You're shitting your pants,
you got problems.
Hip doesn't work,
but I saw him like I'd say last summer,
right?
I'd say months ago.
Makes it seem like the idiot that he
always has been.
I literally have not seen a thing from
him since he's been the governor.
Not a thing.
You sure?
Nothing.
I don't know.
See Yoga,
you get kettle bells.
You get fucking family.
I see that fat fuck from New Jersey all
the time,
but he disappeared for a few months in
New York.
They were asking where he was.
They were going to kill him.
Mean that guy got he.
There were some real shit that happened
when he closed that bridge.
When we get close that bridge.
Some people like we're supposed to go to
the hospital.
Couldn't make it to the hospital as
parents probably.
No,
I'm just saying from Bergen.
Yeah,
North Bergen.
Yeah.
Well he's um,
he's,
he's going to be in hot water for years
for that.
He'll never escape that.
And that's one of the reasons why trump
pulled them from the fucking cabinet and
now he's,
he's criticizing trump.
It's kind of interesting.
I,
Christie,
I never,
he seemed like A.
I loved it.
Like I saw a clip,
pam talent,
some woman at a town hall and sit down
and shut up some screaming about a union
and just fucking,
that's nice when you're local,
you can do.
Exactly.
But I'm saying,
but he still seemed kind of whiny to me.
And then I saw him in the Yankee
uniform.
Oh God.
Jesus h Christ is gaunt,
his lower pussy area was sticking up.
There's no way that guy's seen as Dick.
No one way.
No.
I think his wife could see it from where
she said,
I don't mean to be offensive.
Mr.
looked like an ice cream cone.
It started fucking.
He looks like one of those things that
you use for pastries to write.
Happy Birthday.
Next three bags.
Just squeeze it.
Yes.
Yeah.
Look at that.
What the fuck?
Did he know what he looked like?
He's definitely not one that thing.
He would have been better in a hoop
skirt.
Look,
he wouldn't look.
This poor bastard is an addict.
That is a food addict.
That is 100 percent.
Look at the one above it.
Go to the one above it.
Jamie.
The one which shows his pussy area.
Look at that.
What in the fuck is going on there?
What?
Where's your deck,
Bro?
Holy Christ.
Looks like that.
Looks like Hillary's pantsuit.
A goddamn insane.
That is a goddamn insane pose to.
She never put your hand on your hip like
that.
If you look like this,
don't stand like that.
You should stand like a sumo wrestler at
all times.
You should have a wide stance.
Should never let your legs rub together.
You should be standing like you're ready
to shoot a blast.
Double on.
Don't you have advisors Jan term?
Can you turn my thing up?
Do Control.
My volume was probably over here.
I can't hear myself.
They only got right there.
Is that letter to right there?
That's good.
Yeah.
It was on way low.
He I got to fail.
No.
Even if he was skinny,
we dropped piggy.
Even if even if he was skinny,
he had like a horrible.
Well he doesn't have the best genetics,
but more important than that.
Well,
who knows if he has the best genetics
because I looked it up on the genealogy
site.
Oh,
where's he from?
His mother was a Malibu in Sicily and
I'm not going to be running there.
It looks like Kevin James there.
I could get that fucking guy in shape.
I swear to God.
I swear to God I'd have to do is get
them off.
The sugar would take awhile,
but he's addicted to sugar.
No,
he lives on salads.
They said no dressing.
Writing is a picture of him at the game
and he's got a little bag of m and m's,
a large bag of m and m's and he's
pouring the little bag of m and m's into
the large bag of m and Ms.
I'm not joking.
Look at that.
See?
He's got him with the best and he's a
sugar addict.
See how he's pouring it in there?
Well,
he's my little one into the big one.
You're not fat at all.
No.
I'm just sad.
I don't like sugar,
but I can't.
I was hoping to get a ball so I could
lose this last 20.
That's what happened.
Know you shipped blood for 18 months.
Just don't eat at night.
We talked about this before the podcast.
Don't do that.
I when I heard you say that,
I almost fainted because I've been
saying that to my wife.
I said,
the only time I've ever lost weight my
life is when I'd go to bed hungry.
It's not just that you lose weight.
Your body actually produces more dense
muscle cell or more lean muscle.
Yeah.
When you,
when you're burning fat,
well he's definitely,
but it's also your body has more time to
rebuild your tissue.
You recover better.
It's not just like going to bed hungry
thing.
It's actually good for you just don't.
The idea is as Dr Rhonda Patrick said
this,
you can send like a little African kid,
just a fucking sandwich.
Just you need to edible an edible.
I'm never doing that again.
This is why I love you though,
Joe,
because the last time I was here I go,
uh,
I said,
yeah,
I thought about was like,
I want to take steroids at this age.
I'm fucking sick of working out now.
I've said that to about 20 people and
they were all like,
well,
how do you do that?
You're gonna fucking be kidney.
Had 55.
You looked at me and go,
why wouldn't you do it?
Fuck it.
They work.
There's a reason why you didn't even
hesitate.
You Go,
why wouldn't you with a puzzled look on
your face?
Whenever someone tells me,
Whoa Boon,
you know,
55 years of age,
really think it's a good idea to take
steroids.
Yes,
that's the perfect time.
Yeah,
because you got alternative is dying.
Well also you only have like 20 years
left anyway.
Like what are you going to do that?
That's true.
What are you going to cut it back by?
Five 80.
Oh my God.
Only have 15 years of looking like
fucking sylvester stallone in rocky
four.
Yeah.
You pulled up a picture of him and I
said,
that's.
I said,
that's got to be from 30 years ago.
You're like,
no,
from last Wednesday.
He's 70 years old.
Oh,
100 percent.
How does he not find me?
The doctor.
I'll pay fucking good money.
Get you a doctor.
Testosterone and original rule.
The belly room.
Cousin.
He was doing a set upstairs.
I got a guy.
You gotta meet him with the darks.
Do you have a fake mustache?
Dr Benito Batch.
Well,
testosterone replacement and hormone
replacement therapy is a.
there's a real science to it.
The idea is you don't take too much.
You take what you would have in your
body if you were a younger man.
That's what you do and people are like,
well,
you're not a younger man anymore.
Duh,
like people just want you to wither away
and die.
So you have you jojo.
I take testosterone replacement therapy
and I've done it for almost 10 years
with 49.
Yeah.
Thirty nine started when I was like 39,
37,
38.
I start rubbing this cream on me.
Which wasn't that effective.
Was that the clear?
No,
no.
That's anything I take.
I take mild stuff like that or my dog
and here's the thing about the stuff
that like barry bonds takes and all the
bodybuilders take like they're taking
like hyper human levels.
I don't fuck with anything like that.
What I do is I take what I would have in
my body naturally when I was like 27.
That's what I take so that that is
healthy and that that does almost no
evidence that there's evidence that if
you have a bad heart,
if you're an older person and you start
jacking your body up with testosterone
and doing crazy workouts,
your body's not ready for it,
but also that could be a conditioning
issue.
There's a lot of factors involved in
something like that.
When,
when people go from being sedentary and
out of shape to all of a sudden having
young levels of testosterone and then
get shocked.
Yeah.
So that's when you factor in those
situations with people that have um,
like pretty significant heart issues
after taking testosterone therapy
according to my doctor,
that's what they're dealing with these,
he's like,
you can't,
you have to judge each one of them on an
individual basis and he's also like,
you have to get your blood work done and
you have to be really meticulous about
it was I get my blood work done every
couple of months,
but not just for testosterone,
not just for her,
but also,
yeah,
for bad stuff.
And also for nutrient levels.
I want to make sure,
like I found out that I need more nice
into my system.
I found out I need more vitamin B,
Vitamin D,
three.
D three is a big one.
It's huge.
It's very important.
It's very important for um,
for a muscle is very important for the
way your brain works.
It's also works in symbiosis with a
bunch of other nutrients.
You have to have your,
your nutrient levels tested.
You can't just go on.
I feel pretty good.
You good?
You might feel pretty good,
but there might be.
There might be some fucking shortcomings
in your,
your diet or your,
your supplementation.
I,
you know,
when I play,
I play ball up at Maine in college back
in the eighties and they were all
juicing and I got a lot of teammates who
are like a one guy who saw like a
convalescent home.
I mean they will fucking crazy with the
shit he's in convalescent home now at
55.
He was at.
He's,
Oh my God,
fuck.
And another one.
There's two other guys I know that have
kidney problems from it and they will,
they will muscular.
We were college age kids and they
fucking knit and they would just said,
you know,
that's the whole line was if you want it
to be a pro athlete back then the
fucking Jose Canseco days,
you kinda had to.
Those guys were all gorillas.
Even at Maine.
I go,
Holy Shit,
these guys were so mean.
The lineman and I loved them.
I hung out with them like when they were
not drinking and shit,
but when they would get drunk and they
go,
this isn't main commands,
what goes on at University of Miami or
all these football factories you have.
Can you imagine one AA football?
And I'm like,
this guy's a fucking crazy.
Well that's what gets you and I love him
to death and that's book.
What gets us ahead in this sport were
mean as far as like the shit we crack
jokes on.
Think about the shit that we say when
you and I get together,
we just start fucking around now.
I do observational shit like David.
Brent noticed when a stock goes into the
dryer,
it doesn't come out.
When you breathe out,
where to go,
where that song.
Cool.
There's two songs now.
There's one where to go.
Hicks used to remember you did a bit of
fun of Jerry somebody call balls.
When you think about how we talk when
we're fucking really cool because for us
like that's what gets us ahead is saying
shit that makes us go,
oh Jesus Christ.
Like you'll say some things.
When you're around me that I'm sure you
probably wouldn't say if you're around
other people and I will do the same way.
You know,
that's my problem.
I say it everywhere.
That's how football players,
that's why I'm in.
Yeah,
no,
I said you're right.
Fighters like that.
Yeah.
Fighters will like that.
It's the same way.
I had a buddy of mine,
my friend Mike Blight from South Boston
and uh,
he was,
he was very humble looking like he used
to wear glasses and,
but he's a psycho.
He's a psycho as they come and he wore.
He's a very smart guy and he wore like a
golf shirt and he used to like a polo
shirt.
So he looked like a fucking dork.
He had his shirt tucked in,
his pants was belt the whole deal.
And he worked at the rat.
You remember the rats?
Yeah.
Yes.
Well he was a bouncer there and people
would give him a hard time because the
way he looked,
he was just waiting for someone to say
something stupid so he could rearrange
their face.
Just,
he's a pro boxer.
He was always,
but he was almost setting them up by
wearing the shirt and just setting them
up like a trap.
Like he was beat boy duck.
He was a straight up psycho and he
would,
he would,
he wouldn't wait for someone to get out
of line and do something to him,
push him,
grab his shirt,
and then next thing they'll cook crack
dudes or flatline and spasming going
into seizures.
Yeah.
This kid,
this kid,
Danny,
I won't say that,
but for these guys are from the Cape.
They,
you know,
they played football down in Cape in
high school and they were friends.
But this one guy Danny mcclung used to,
he was big fucking.
He had these dead,
dead eyes,
those,
those Pale blue eyes and you know,
they look sad.
You know,
I'm in the like,
sag down.
And uh,
when he got drunk,
I mean he was like fucking Clint
Eastwood in unforgiven when he would get
drunk as well.
Your money where your money killer of
women and children.
We have two dogs and our fraternity,
two little dogs,
a white woman.
I'm black.
He threw them in a punch bowl.
Oh,
well that's really my white one was
written.
No,
he didn't hurt them,
but I'm just saying I thought you going
to say wood chipper and and then he hits
that beating up men,
women,
whoever looked at him wrong.
Yeah.
There's guys like and a few other
lineman.
I shouldn't have singled him out.
He was actually.
People feed off each other.
That's why mob mentality is work.
The reason why the mob mentality exists
because someone sees someone doing
something crazy
and the other people get crazy too,
and here's the thing we need to
recognize right now that's going on like
uc Berkeley.
That is mob mentality.
That doesn't.
That's not justice.
It's not rational.
It's not a real fucking protest.
That is a goddamn mob and they are
rioting and they're wrong.
They're wrong because that guy,
all he wants to do is talk.
If someone wants to talk and which you
want to do is light the fucking campus
on fire and throw a fucking chair
through a plate glass window at
starbucks.
That is a mob mentality and it's the
same goddamn thing and not only that,
but all you're doing is pumping him up.
It's the streisand effect.
Do you keep him from fucking pro to keep
him from speaking?
You make him bigger.
He's going to be even larger now because
of that and you're just showing
everybody what you're making.
You lost the battle of ideas when you do
that.
That's when it gets in the battle of
ideas.
That's what I'm saying.
This Nazi thing is fucking crazy where
everybody calls everybody a Nazi.
We're talking about the Sarah Silverman
thing before the podcast.
I don't know if she was joking around or
not,
but she put on her twitter.
Is this like a Nazi who doesn't know how
to make a swastika and everybody just
tore apart because everybody wants to
call everybody a Nazi today and those
symbols on the ground,
it's what people do when their surveyors
and they want to mark where the power is
or the gas lines are.
They have specific lines so that like
it's specific colors for electricity,
a different color for gas line and she's
like,
oh look,
there's she can the swastika.
Yeah.
Out of anything.
It's like,
what the fuck is going on with everybody
calling everybody?
Well,
that's like an old ploy from the law.
I'm 55.
I mean every republican that ever ran
since I've been know was always a label
that Nazi and they see that this is the
line walking to get coffee.
Saw these Oliver Sidewalk and tournament
is an attempt at Swastika,
goes to neo Nazis not have google.
Just.
It's a combination of she's being silly.
You should be instead of to them both.
You can take it either way.
Okay.
It's a construction that Arthur innocent
mistake for a Jew.
That gut gets burnt in an oven.
What?
At least weekly on twitter.
Still pretty close though.
Oh No,
it's the wrong way.
And an s with a line and it looks like
Swanson's dinners every once in a minute
joke,
a dyslexic to the dyslexic German kid.
Draw this,
uh,
you know,
something of that.
Well,
I don't know,
just she's got big innocent mistake.
She says,
well,
it's so when it gets burned into
twitter,
so she's because of the shit that people
say to her on twitter.
She's saying that's why she's doing it.
She lost me on the,
uh,
the oven thing.
I think what she's trying to do is take
some of the blame away from her for
putting something ridiculous on twitter
and by saying that people tell her to
get an oven because she's a Jew and this
is why she's sensitive.
Oh No.
This Nazi thing that everybody's saying,
punch Nazis.
If you've seen this slightly,
we should punch Nazis like campus Nazi.
Can anybody who doesn't think like who's
anybody who doesn't think like a fucking
left these a Nazi.
It's very crazy.
It's very,
it's a very crazy thing we've got
going on now because by calling someone
a Nazi,
you can immediately hit them.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
it's way out of whack.
It's real weird way out of fucking
whack.
I'm hoping it settles down,
but I don't think it's gonna.
I feel like this trump thing is just
going to ramp up because he keeps doing
stupid shit.
Like the way he's disagreeing with the
Supreme Court.
See you in court.
What court?
Which court?
They just,
you were in court.
You just lost in court.
You won't see him in court again.
Like what?
Go to the Supreme Court now.
Okay.
See you in another court.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm undecided on that.
I understand why he tweets because they,
you know,
the fucking media is just ridiculously
unfair to him.
So,
but,
but he does it too much.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean wait for big things and,
and yet.
But you know.
Yeah.
You don't have to be.
How do you feel like during unfair
there?
I'm like,
what do you think is unfair?
I know I shouldn't have said that.
No,
I'm just asking.
Just just hitting me.
Just give me a specific example about
them.
Like how so?
Well,
what did I see this morning?
Oh,
he had a meeting down at Mara Lago.
He was down there as his place in
Florida and they were talking about,
uh,
I guess they were talking about Russia
at the table and the headlines on CNN.
He's discussing a military secrets and
in public,
you know,
at my,
what's it called?
Trump turns the lago club situation
room.
I mean,
everything he does,
Joe,
he did,
you know,
they usually get a new presidents get a
fucking honeymoon.
This guy has been under attack.
It's just ridiculous.
Well,
I mean everything he says they fucking
go after him,
but don't think that he is also
instigating a lot of this.
But like when he pointed it from CNN and
said,
you're fake news.
That was refreshing to me.
Well,
I had been saying that since 1988 before
I even follow politics.
I go,
does anybody watch this fucking network
and see how fucking stupid it is?
I mean,
they blatantly fucking left wing.
Well,
they're blatantly leftwing.
Fox is blatantly right.
When you switched back and forth,
you don't get.
They get,
you get both.
And I love having this dragon because
everybody says that to me.
I go,
well,
do you watch fox?
And I it not,
wouldn't,
it's too stupid.
Then how the fuck do you know?
You get both.
There's people at Fox who hate trump.
I spend time over there.
I know.
Who is this that this guy's on during
the day?
A fucking shepard.
Smith fucking hates them.
Um,
who else?
There's a woman who has Smith's,
an interesting character.
Does he admit he's gay?
Uh,
I keep telling him,
but he won't admit it.
He looked beautiful.
He attacked me if I was gay,
what?
He attacked me and him and judging the
is like a real,
real innocent for what Nikki didn't
provoke that did in the judge did it?
Yeah.
Like pilot fan.
He wants to come on the podcast.
I've got to get that guy on.
We were talking about what a bad ass is.
The uh,
the Strat is something called the
strategy room.
He has a goal set us up.
No,
it was a streaming show on Fox.
What did you do wrong?
I showed up,
be honest,
and we're talking about the elections
and I go,
well,
the fucking media was in the tank for
Obama and Shepard Smith.
I just met him.
He sitting there and they fucking double
teamed me.
Huh?
He goes,
it's so typical.
You're the type of guy you could tell he
hated it.
He must have known me from like tough
crowd or whatever and my politics.
You could tell it was something before I
met him that.
Well,
whenever you have to blame every.
Yeah,
you have to blame.
You're the type of guy that has to play
him.
Everybody.
He went off like a fucking fight and for
once in my life I sort of sat there
like,
like high,
like a mature because he was making an
ass of himself.
Oh,
so you let them?
Yeah.
Wow.
Where'd you get that restraint?
I don't know.
That day,
that day was just there.
Just for that five minutes.
I've never had it again.
Let's six.
I was in the tank.
I was too lazy to fight back.
No,
I was in a fog.
I'm in the Fox building.
I was trying to show some respect where
you could tell he has since asked me to
come on his show.
So if you haven't.
No,
I couldn't.
I was going,
I was on the road or something he wanted
but,
but I don't punch shit against anybody
because um,
you know,
I fly off the handle all the time,
but it came out of,
I could tell he must've known my comedy
and didn't like it,
but it was homophobic or whatever the
fuck.
I mean,
yeah,
probably that,
you know what I mean.
And so we went with the right wing
thing.
Yeah.
Well he said you have the type of person
as to blame people.
I didn't know what the fuck that meant.
I'm a big fan of blaming people,
especially when you do something.
Totally blame them.
That's how we show that to them.
It's all good.
I'm stupid.
I know.
But uh,
they learn if you don't blame them.
But yeah,
I mean if they don't,
if you don't blame them,
they just keep going.
They go like people.
My mother always used to say to me,
you don't let anything go.
And I go,
I still don't at this age,
if an eight year old girl fucking gives
me lip and I think she's wrong,
I'll tell her why.
You know why it's a teaching moment that
once president so let them know.
Otherwise they don't know.
It's a learning moment.
I think of it like that.
Yeah.
If you don't let them know,
you know what happens?
You get spoiled kings.
I mean that's what a spoiled kings
that's now my next cd.
That's a good idea.
I mean that's what someone is when they,
they just,
anyone can tell them anything.
I mean that's what you always say about
like super rich celebrities.
You always hear that about people that
are untouchable.
They don't speak to like when Meryl
Streep got in front of all those people
and was given a speech,
you know,
and she was going off with that.
That is someone that never has anyone
talking to her and correcting her and
telling her how ridiculous.
Well that's like,
that's 98 percent of Hollywood.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Especially really famous people like
when you get into that Tom Cruise realm
where they just don't communicate with
anybody.
Right.
That's,
that's,
that's not a good thing.
It's a good thing,
you know,
one call you out on your shit.
You mean fucking Tom Cruise's sous chef
might not be Republican.
Tom Cruise sous chef was from fucking
planet feet and for sure I learned that
from Leah Remini.
Everybody around.
That guy's a scientologist.
Everyone you know.
I didn't know that.
Giovanni Ribisi is a scientologist,
so now I see that ad for his new show.
I'm like looking at crazy.
Fuck.
Who is that?
I said no,
that Giovanni Ribisi.
He's been in a shitload of movies.
Very good actor,
but he's in the Irish Amazon things.
Sneaky Pete.
There he is.
That guy.
Scientology as fuck.
Look at.
Look at that mustache.
That looks that one though.
Yeah,
look at that.
That's a look.
What the Hell [inaudible] ladies imagine
that look.
Chilling down on your box.
A.
Yeah.
He's a scientologist.
He looks at it says,
it is amazing that there's still people
in that amazing.
There's only 10,000
people according to Leah Remini,
how many edits worldwide,
how many edits?
Oh fuck,
fuck.
Load.
Yeah.
They have so much money though.
What's incredible is those people have
donated so much money.
They like the number two real estate
holders in Los Angeles.
They're all over the place.
They're like starbucks.
A lot of cash they ever miscavige.
They're a good group to have behind you.
If they're behind you.
Look,
if you're a scientologist and you're
also like an actor or something like
that,
they'll fucking insulate you again.
That's what I wanted to ask her if I
haven't met her.
Because you had a lot of success while
you were doing that,
like in your profession as an accurate.
Did you attribute it to.
Do you think scientology help you?
She definitely did at one point in time.
Yeah.
I think what you think about the work
that's involved,
like she was telling me that everyday
they'd have to do two and a half hours
where the work every day you're
constantly working on it and constantly
like reading the stuff and going over
things.
I think anytime you have that kind of
discipline that translates over to other
things like people ask me like,
how can you like,
why do you have so much discipline?
Like with comedy or with all the like
how much you work so hard because I had
to do with fighting.
With fight.
If you don't have discipline with
fighting,
you get fucked up.
That's just the way it is.
You get your good sports are very good.
Kids guns,
good to lose.
We don't want to have chem class.
It's unfair.
Shut the fuck up if you don't.
I know a comic,
I won't say his name,
but he's been pretty open about it,
about one of the reasons why he's fucked
up as an adult because his parents
didn't encourage him to do anything
competitive when he was young,
so he didn't learn to live.
Mark Marin,
you didn't learn how to lose.
Yeah.
That seems like that seems like half the
fucking Democrats now.
Yeah.
You got a freaking out that trump won.
I'm like,
did any of these people play sports
seriously?
I think there's a lot of people that are
freaking out that trump won because this
guy is,
first of all,
he's not using the secrets where it was
used.
His own security people is tweeting
bigger problems and it's got a black
guy.
Oh,
he's got a android phone that someone
could easily hack into.
He's,
he's a maniac.
He's basically running things his way.
Like he does a business and you got
abandoned all of the visitor.
It's not really a corporation.
That's all I've been hearing from the
left since I was 10 years old.
Now you get a businessman.
They rapidly.
You're eating wood over there.
He's gone crazy fever.
This coffee stirrers drank caveman
coffee,
fucking the homeless,
homeless.
This and I got to get on the plane in a
couple hours.
I'm going to be shitting blood.
You say you're going to be very creative
on that plane.
I hope you brought a laptop.
You're going to have some thoughts.
I have a coloring book and uh,
what else am rushack prints from my
childhood?
You could write in your phone.
I got to get a new mug.
A take that tip my hat with you,
I'll give you a pen and you generate
some great jokes
all the way home.
Do you know,
you mentioned that earlier you write
when you're fucking high,
right?
All the time.
Yeah.
Almost sober.
I write sober.
I do everything sober and high.
They do both.
I take a couple excedrin pm before I
write and that's why I've slowed down as
far as productive now.
Um,
you,
you fucking.
Yeah.
Well I think,
uh,
I gotta believe Steven Wright used to
write like that,
right?
I don't think he did.
No,
I think he's just a really bright guy.
You know,
Stephen writes stuff is almost like too
obscure to right when you're high.
Used to work in a fire hydrant plant.
Couldn't park anywhere near the place.
That kind of stuff.
He,
he,
me and him hung out for a week doing
horace and Pete.
Louisa.
Oh yeah.
Thing he did.
Uh,
so me and steven became like asshole
buddies for that week out of my mouth.
He'd be puking belly laughing it insane
here.
And,
and then Louie had ellen all the same,
all this racist shit as this racist old
bartender.
I mean dropping the n bomb and shit.
Did you ever see,
I never saw horace and Pete,
is it only online on Lewis website or is
it somewhere else?
No,
I don't.
That's a great question.
It's got to be,
it's going to end up.
I got a blade has got end up on Netflix
when I felt like,
I felt like I'm just gonna wait.
But he had,
he had,
uh,
he had a woman,
one of the characters had tourette's and
she'd yell out like,
fucking Edward and shit now fucking,
you know.
And I can't even say it even on your
podcast,
but me and steven would look at each
other,
you know,
he'd be sitting here at the end of the
bar and I'd see his shoulders because
Alan Alda,
the Edward Halk IPF is like being this
racist and low.
He had this girl that was supposed to
have tourette's in the show saying the
most heinous shit you have ever heard.
And me and steven comics within comics
that whole life.
So you think it'd be jaded at that,
but only low he could come up with shit.
So outrageous.
But to see it coming out of hock ips is
molly.
I'm liberal from the west side was
making me hard.
That's hilarious.
And Steven was crying it put his head
down,
you know,
they would.
Dad Is fucking hilarious.
What did he do?
Horace and Pete with like real people
and then animated over the real peoples
and how he did it.
No,
he shot it.
He shot it like a,
a play.
So it's not an animated.
No,
no,
no.
There was an animation.
So please watch it.
I love it.
This is how low he described that one of
the interviews because it's like really
dark and kind of.
He goes,
it's kind of depressing and shit.
it's like the show cheers.
If everybody had cancer around the bar,
you will.
You'll lead it up.
Okay.
First of all,
from the same hometown,
right?
Is Louis?
Yeah.
You'll fucking eat it up.
It's,
it's.
I think it's the best shit he's ever
done.
He said,
whoa.
Why didn't he let go broke making it?
He,
well he wouldn't really know exactly.
Emptied is whatever you have laying
around.
He went on stern to explain these people
going broke and he went on Sterno one of
these radio shows that he went,
oh,
I didn't go.
He goes,
every every production company when
they're doing a production is in the
red.
He goes,
I'll go tour for three months and I'll
make my money back.
But he.
Yeah.
He spent a ton of his own money.
Yeah,
that's what I so ballsy of him.
It's so funny when people say that,
like Louis C,
k.broker,
the Lucy does one show and he's not
broke anymore.
Do you understand that?
Because you Madison Square Garden and
make more than you do in 10 years.
When I'm tired.
He just wanted hour.
He makes like years and years of salary.
Like stop.
He's not broke.
No,
exactly.
Yeah.
You'll eat the shit up.
I'm telling you.
I'm sure at one thing he's ever done
that I don't like.
He is so he,
he,
he goes,
come over to my house.
This was before he did horace and Pete.
I saw him at the comedy cellar,
he goes,
give me a ride home.
So he goes,
come in,
and he showed that I'm working on the.
He goes,
read this,
and I read some fucking shit.
And then I know a week later he goes,
come to my house tomorrow for lunch.
I,
I fucked.
I rang the doorbell.
Alan Alda opens the door.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Where does he live?
A exactly.
He said,
give us extra address.
He's a to 11 bleecker street,
apartment three C,
fourth floor.
Got a red door.
Dong.
He's,
yeah,
he lives out in,
within a half mile the comedy cellar
somewhere here.
And he just bought another thing.
So He's,
he's got a lot of moves around.
But I saw Alan all the answers that
door.
I uh,
I,
I go in the kitchen.
Steve is Jamie's in the kitchen.
I'm making all these.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
you know who ed?
Ed Falco rings the doorbell like five
minutes later and was sitting there
reading this current nanny show.
Huh?
What did the nurse and nurse,
Jackie,
she got Kinda mad at me because I go,
I went up there.
I said,
I go,
you are one of the best actors I've,
uh,
you know,
I got.
I'm still hung up on the car.
I go,
I still watched the sopranos,
like on a loop.
And she goes,
that's too bad.
And she like walked away I think
because,
you know,
actors,
famous people that if you don't know the
latest work,
they get kind of bent out of shape.
Oh really?
She hadn't bent out of shape a little
bit.
That's how I read it.
Just takes herself seriously.
Just like this fucking asshole.
I saw Shepard Smith tell you a new
asshole.
She loved me.
No,
she was,
she loved me.
She was working with Ferrara.
Ferrara was on that nurse.
Jackie and she,
she's a,
she was great.
I had a little line or two with her.
She was a bartender,
but you gotta watch it just to see the
woman with Tourette's.
She'll be right in the middle of like a
serious conversation.
Look my buzzer.
You fucking asshole.
Whoa.
And I look over at Steven Wright and
he's trying to put his head down and I
supposed to be.
And then Louie Louie would be behind the
bar,
right.
In some scenes he'd be bartending and
like Ed fail.
Colby having a chat with some other
actors in the scene.
He'd come over to meet and like had a
little piece of paper had drawn shit
like a big Dick.
I mean he is God.
He hands me.
He hands me a note and it says we used
to do the knotty pine for $75.
Do you remember that Gig?
And Quincy called the knotty pine.
Yeah,
I do remember that.
Good.
He hands me that and I,
I,
I turned it off.
I wrote back,
I go,
I'm doing it next week.
One hundred 25 Gig.
Yes.
It was very casual.
It was like a dance floor.
Those are the best.
Bring you onto the ball spinning.
And they'd go,
okay,
get off the dance.
But we got a comedian coming up till you
get in a fistfight and one of those
places I guess just to actual comedy
clubs to actual comedy clubs.
Giggles and Seattle and giggles and
Boston.
What should down anymore?
Right.
That was like a real.
Wasn't it like a real Christian room or
something like that?
You had to be clean.
No,
no,
fuck no.
He hit me in a headlock.
You would've loved it.
Yeah.
Two,
two different incidents.
And with my act I was talking about with
the woman who runs the club in Chicago.
I go,
I've only been in like,
I've only had two altercations.
And she goes,
that's it with that fucking.
I go,
exactly.
I'd and say that's pretty damn good.
That is pretty good.
Um,
broke my hands in both though.
I have hands punching people.
Jesus,
you.
I mean they fucking punching back joke.
Don't act like throw elbows.
Very difficult to break.
Oh you have to teach me.
I'll show you.
But I got the shoulders of 100 year old
man.
You know,
didn't you have like you had serious
surgery,
reconstruction on both of them.
Does it feel good now?
Do they feel they never bothered me.
I went on to play.
I wasn't supposed to have the high
school.
The guy did them right up to high school
and they told me you shouldn't really go
play.
And I went up to Maine and blade
football and the guy did such a good
job.
I still remember his name,
lyle mchaley.
He still gives speeches about that.
He's got to be in his seventies now.
Wow.
And he did such a great job of putting
my shoulders back together that I played
a couple years in college and they're
fine and,
and,
and I don't even have pain lake when I
wake up at them.
I'm sure that's going to change in her
week.
But uh,
well do you do exercises with them yet?
Well,
I,
you know,
I work out,
but for exercises specifically for
shoulders,
I just start now and within the last few
years because I had shoulder injuries,
but one of the best ones ever is
kettlebells.
Well,
kettlebells,
I think you showed me,
I don't think I showed you this because
I've recently gotten into what the fuck?
That 120 pounds.
No,
there's only 40 pounds.
But you do bottoms up,
meaning you hold it like this.
So you have to balance it.
Stabilization Muscles.
Oh yeah.
Constantly adjusting and move.
And then that lands on your nose.
No,
it's all good for your grip too.
So you work on those and.
Well,
you know,
it's good to say it for me.
I used to laugh at people that use the
uh,
you know,
what those meetings,
those flies.
Yeah,
those are good.
Those are good.
It's good for you.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I never used to do specific shoulder
exercises.
I did everything in the shoulders.
Got worked well.
I was doing all those things,
but I never did specific shoulder
exercises until I had a shoulder
industry.
Yeah.
Then I started doing a lot of rotation
exercises,
all these different things to build up
the rotator cuff and stuff.
So right after the surgery I did a ton
of it.
Yeah.
You got to do all that stuff.
This guy was so good.
Lyle,
mckayla.
I went to a doctor a couple of years ago
in New York in Westchester county where
I live because I was having problems
with my road and he goes,
boy,
what's with the scars?
I go ahead,
uh,
something called a bankart procedure
back in the eighties and he and uh,
I go,
a guy named lyle mckayla did.
He goes,
I'll be damned.
I went to a convention.
I've been harvard.
Dad talked his convention.
He was speaking about shoulder injuries,
angry at sky back then.
And uh,
God bless my parents to find like a
decent doctor and yeah,
he did a fucking job.
I can't.
Right after I had them done,
I couldn't bench heavy anymore and share
it,
you know,
I mean,
you're stuck behind my neck is a lot of
people don't believe in bench and heavy.
Anyway.
Gretchen heavy just fucks your
shoulders.
That's,
that's how I originally fuck them up.
Yeah.
Especially back in the eighties,
nobody knew about warming up and
stretching.
I was like,
benching with alignment.
And what happens is you're still growing
at that point.
You were a big fuck when I first met
you,
when I first met you,
one of the,
it was very encouraging to me because,
uh,
I had always thought that to be a comic
you had to be out of shape and goofy
looking and I always felt they hate us.
Yeah.
I felt like I didn't belong.
And then Joe onstage killen and I was
like,
I want to be okay,
but you know what?
They fucking still hit.
Nothing has changed.
Well,
barren even admitted it to me.
Like when I did his podcast,
he was saying like,
you shouldn't,
you shouldn't be doing this.
This is our thing.
And I was like,
well that's crazy.
That was the mentality.
It's like,
what are you talking about?
What does that got to do with being
funny?
I love this idea.
You have to have low self esteem,
shitty parents,
a shitty upbringing.
You have to punch up.
I think it's funny when you punched
down,
will that punch punching a little kid in
the back of the head?
There's definitely things that are
funnier than that.
No,
I don't have kids.
You're healthier punching,
kill kids,
kids that deserve no Irish kids,
but the punch and I had an argument with
a be canvas professor who's a,
wrote a book on comedy.
Remember that guy?
He just does his name.
He wrote a book on on Compton.
He was like,
well,
punching up is always was always
funnier,
and I'm like,
okay,
that's not true.
That's not true.
Sam kinisons bit about starving kids in
Africa is one of the greatest bits of
all time as punching down as you ever
can get because it's so fucked up.
You're listening to Eco Jesus.
I can't believe he's saying this and
you're fucking crying.
Laughing.
Funny is funny.
Well,
you acquainted,
you know like sports and comedy,
like you said,
football and fighting.
I want.
I'm going to fight.
I throw up,
down sideways every day.
Right?
And a lot of ways.
Yeah.
They come from punches come from
everywhere.
Exactly.
That's why this whole thing about
punching down so fucking stupid or the
idea that you have to be a Dork in order
to be funny.
Some of the funniest people I ever met
were savages.
Like that's where I learned how to do
comedy.
He was in the gym.
I know guys.
That's the reason why I got into stand
up in the first place.
I would make people laugh when we were
on a bus on the way that tournament.
It was like gallows humor.
Everybody was scared and I would be the
guy who is making everybody laugh.
There were all savages.
Yeah.
Those guys are Tan with the linemen that
took the kids there.
There was some of the funniest
motherfuckers have ever met in my life
and not dumb jock.
Funny.
They,
I mean they would actually come up with
clever shit and.
But uh,
yeah that was the mentality.
Like Kevin Flynn,
I remember good soccer player.
Umass.
He was like a real good soccer,
really good soccer player.
Right.
And,
and,
uh,
he used to talk about because him,
him and me came together at the Boston
scene.
He was another one and they hated us.
Jeannine,
I tell and I love fucking gene.
I still do.
The first night I met Janine,
it was fucking like open mic.
Alright.
I've been in the business about fucking
eight months,
10 months,
maybe it was that stitches.
I walk in sitting in the little
box office,
she goes nice acid washed jeans and they
weren't,
they were faded,
who actually faded.
They were fair to.
She goes nice acid washed jeans and I'd
never met before.
I'd go.
Nice.
I go nice boots where they going to
clamming lady account.
That's how I met Janeane Garofalo and
it.
And it didn't even phase her,
which made me like her number one.
She didn't even fucking,
she kind of like smirked and,
and then um,
and people even now my friends don't
believe that you.
How do you like her comedy?
And I watched her,
it stitches going in after Steve
Sweeney,
you know,
the whole boys club.
And I did that young comedian specials.
She always had her own point of view
when Shit,
you know,
it's not a,
but my friends always never believed
that.
Uh,
I thought you liked that kind of thing.
She's funny.
We used to play softball with her.
She used to.
She used to be on the comedian softball
thing.
I used to meet on Mondays were in New
York.
No,
Boston.
Yeah,
Dave Cross was in it.
Um,
there was a lot of people,
some good athletes.
Janine,
David Cross,
Brian Frazier.
You ever?
He was another one.
What happened to him?
Joe?
I think he's writing now.
He was another one.
That guy was giant.
He was fucking built like a brick shit
house.
One time he went on stage with a shirt
on like a golf shirt after I got them
upstairs.
You Go,
dude,
you can't dress like that.
I go,
look,
I'm your friend and I can't stop staring
at your arms.
Like you can't.
You can't dress like that because he was
a bodybuilder at one point in time.
They got really big.
Absolutely right.
And who else?
There was another.
Oh,
Brian Kylie.
Kylie was a gorilla and he's like a
really cerebral,
right?
Yeah.
So yeah,
that whole myth of,
you know,
they do resent yet and I still feel like
an outsider in this business.
I still,
I got a couple friends,
you know,
fucking putting an outsider at all.
Well,
you know Colin Quinn is like,
you know,
we're on the phone every night.
He's probably my closest and Louis,
but they're not.
I don't have much in common with them
outside of outside of the shell
business.
Well you can't go to the UCB.
I have just to ruin the night,
go in and I blow it up and I go follow
that.
Go fuck another mediocre story with two
punch lines every 30 minutes.
Well go there and not get paid to.
I'm about that stupid fucks.
The that allowed these people to create
an empire with not paying millions.
That is so disgusting.
This Duncan trussell had a whole bit
about it.
Like it's like,
what have you done?
Like you've decided to do this one
thing,
this one place where the cerebral people
go,
you make all the money.
That's not very cerebral.
Right?
That seems pretty fucking stupid.
How'd they do that?
How do they get away with that?
I don't know.
I don't understand it.
People.
There's always people who want to be in
the arts.
They will fucking work,
but nothing and.
Yeah,
and they also want to be in the inside.
They want to be on the inside.
Yeah.
I never felt that way.
They want to be in the clinic,
got to go there to click like a,
like Patton Oswald,
who I've,
you know,
he came on tough crowd and um,
he almost insinuated that I was like a
Dick joke specialism in
even calling.
We like fucking what we,
you know that your addiction
specialists.
Yeah.
I made a joke on that episode,
a Black Dick joke or something and he
kind of implied that's what I do is
something like me and turned on him and
uh,
and I'm like,
Eh,
I never,
I always thought he's kind of overrated
as a stamp,
but I've really grown to love his stand
out or stand ups.
Very good.
Yeah.
He's um,
he's a great guy but he's a nerdy who we
have nothing in common.
And sometimes when I like people like
that,
they don't necessarily,
I think via like more the so called
tolerant crowd is a lot less tolerant
than I am.
It's true.
It is true that you mean tower people,
would they consider themselves to be
progressive?
People are oftentimes very intelligent.
Not Actually.
He's a good dude.
I hit him up on twitter and you know,
and the so,
you know,
actually,
but um,
yeah,
I,
I still feel I,
I don't watch movies.
I hate what the political correctness,
which I haven't,
you know,
Big Bang theory and shit.
Like what am I doing?
You know,
his wife died from that fucking fentanyl
shit.
She's another the.
Is that what caused her that?
God Damn Fentanyl,
the same shit that killed prince,
same shit that killed a buddy of mine
was the autumn season.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
It was a combination of things with
fentanyl was in the mix because he said
no,
not too long ago.
He said he thought it was like an
accidental overdose.
Right.
Fucking horrible man.
Fentanyl is supposedly hundreds of
times,
hundreds of thousands of times stronger.
Someone was explaining it the other day.
It's stronger than opiod than regular
opiods.
Yeah.
It was a horse sterilizer,
a horse tranquilizer rather than.
That's not good.
Yeah,
it's fucking terrifying.
Terrifying Shit.
That stuff they decided that uh,
oxycontins are killing people quick
enough so they,
they came up with this stuff and if you
fuck up one way or the other with that
fentanyl,
just a slight overdose.
I'm a puss or drugs.
I'm a put that.
Fentanyl Shit is terrifying.
It's killing people like crazy.
But you like your mushrooms and share,
right?
You stuff's.
I would never do that in a trillion us.
Oh,
you should do it.
Definitely do it.
It's good for.
And you kidding me.
I told you the oedipal story.
I might as well been doing.
Mushroom kills the ego.
It's good for you.
It kills it for a long good to step
outside yourself and see who you all my
ego.
I come back,
it'll come back.
I'm just saying that like it gives you
the street now.
She'll go crazy.
She'll shit her pants.
So yeah,
be terrible.
She'd be like that bathtub girl here.
See the bathtub girl?
No one in the Japanese lady with her
asshole on the air.
Shit spraying up in the air and hit her
in the face.
That was Margaret Cho's last specialists
that we've talking about.
Come on
guys.
Fucking La Faggots,
safe bagging all
the time and I will continue to say,
wow,
I always call.
I said that on stage and then I,
I've faggot.
I think low.
He actually had a bit about it,
but I,
I've called everybody but gay person a
faggot.
My brother and I'll fucking Louis don't
get word.
Yeah,
it's a good word.
And I said that on the unmasked thing I
did with Ron Bennington.
He goes,
so you think that makes it right?
And I go,
yeah.
Ron Bennington was trying to progressive
you.
How dare he girls show him,
love him.
He's a good guy in my house.
Show isn't just whole.
Ron Bennington's whole show is what?
Breaking down.
Silly.
Uh,
is it rally hard to listen to them and
it's a fun show.
I love him.
He's smart and funny.
I don't hear it anymore.
I don't have serious anymore.
I stopped with the.
You realized that because I'm going to
do.
I might get a show on there.
Well,
I'll get it off bittorrent.
That sign I,
I even know about that aren't just put
it online.
I'll get.
I just did.
I think that car.
What do you.
V Eight car and you go into a tunnel.
It doesn't work.
I've refused to support that Chris
Christie,
but I think it's fucking stupid.
I think it's stupid.
I think satellite is stupid I think and
I think you live in the dark ages
because I go through the time I go
through the tunnels in New Jersey now
you can listen to satellite radio
tunnel,
regular radio,
but not satellite radio.
They have ready radio signals.
They have transmitters in the title and
have a little freak.
Absolutely right.
Yeah.
Satellite doesn't work.
No wonder if you could you try to get
uh,
get the signal in La.
You go under a bridge,
like an overpass.
It doesn't work.
Fuck you.
So that means someone could be talking
about some important shit.
I have to stop traffic and I'd be like,
hold on.
Did people beep?
And I'm like,
I don't want to cut out.
I see the red light.
I know I've done that.
I've pulled that.
I've been pulling into my garage and
I'll hear you on to somebody.
I like Louis or whatever and that
affects my back out of my garage.
That's what.
No,
no,
I agree with you.
And commercials to.
We're going to have strings on our roof
that go directly to the transmitter.
Far.
We have wired cars.
Will wires are criss crossing each
other?
Well,
it's fucking stupid.
It's a stupid technology.
They won't take the job that was
internet.
The Internet is the way to go.
Goddammit.
You went to other people have figured it
out.
That's not true.
A lot of people figured it out.
Joey Diaz gets millions of downloads a
month now because he,
you know,
because of him because he's fucking
funny.
You know?
I know he's funny.
I'm just saying.
But you started them off for.
You didn't have to do the same for you.
Neck.
Well,
we can help you.
Come sit down.
Rub My back with Joe.
Joey did.
He didn't seem like champagne with me
pulling this rope and make sure that I
came out here.
Seriously.
That's why I came up.
Because when,
by the way,
hit me up at Nick Depalo and twitter and
instagram and all that other shit.
You people,
it's out fat.
Oh my goodness.
Are you fucking children of the coin?
It's on my twitter.
You can find them.
Uh,
but um,
no,
but when I last time I did the show.
I did twice,
right?
I go home before Christ.
By the time I get home I had like 500
new followers,
like on twitter because I go,
what the fuck kind of rocket ship is he
driving here?
Well,
it's way crazier now because the last
time you hear it was what?
A year ago.
How long was it?
I,
it's either a year or two.
Jamie knows he's got it in a folder
called,
but it is the number of downloads that
we've had since then is like more than
10 times.
And why is that Joe?
I don't know.
Something's happened.
I think you're talented,
motherfucker.
Thanks Sweetie.
That's so nice.
July last year.
Actually.
Twenty 15.
Thank you.
Okay.
I believe when the year came by,
I told you I was going to come out every
year at least once a year time.
I was even thinking every six months or
whatever,
they call me up.
You can come anytime you want.
You told me that you all open the place
oil and uh,
but,
but here's the thing.
And,
and a year what came?
I'm a guy who I should be going out to
Joseph.
I couldn't get off the couch.
I go,
I can't fucking go to laguardia.
Go through all that hard too hard out
there.
It's don't.
It is.
But um,
no.
I'm just saying this show is like I was
saying at the Queen on the phone,
I go,
do you doing enrollments?
Punk guy.
It's like doing a TV show.
Somebody said,
are you going to do corn on a drill?
I go into Joe's podcast.
I do know and I love Conan.
I'm just Colin's.
He wouldn't sell me on it anyways.
He,
he doesn't like,
you know,
he loves me.
I'm just saying I wouldn't use social
media.
I could have plugged that.
I guess.
You know what?
The problem is you won't shine on Conan
seven minutes,
the way you shine and a couple of hours
does a couple of hours things.
What's up?
Yeah,
see he's pointing at me for people
listening.
Smiling cameras.
Yeah,
but a lot of people were listening way
more people who are listening and
watching a four minute.
You're right.
A four minute interview on her as
opposed to a Joe Rogan doing a.
I was supposed to do seth Myers last
week and it got canceled because of the
snow storms.
My flight got canceled and I was going
to do his show because I really like
him.
I think he does a great job.
He's funny.
He's an old lack of anymore.
I used to fuck.
He's turning on lefty on lefty.
What his first 10 minutes make the daily
show.
Looked like a Fox news channel,
but doesn't it make sense what he's
saying?
Can't you see you're on team fucking
Ryan.
I'm not an entity's.
I'm different than you.
Oh yeah,
I'm on team.
Right?
You talking about the left?
I'm not.
Okay.
Again,
that's one.
That's one issue.
How about that?
I'm just to hunt.
I cook roasts,
commentator,
so a hippie.
You do psychedelics and the but how am I
in team?
Right?
You definitely funny.
I.
I approached Goddammit job.
This was going so well.
I'm fucking pro,
like I said in this business that
consider me conservative,
but I fucking gate.
No problem with gay marriage either side
of the keep don't put yet.
I would like to watch an episode of
chopped where it's not a girl with a
crew cut and free reigns in on.
Knows what the hell is a network show?
Jamie knows I'm talking about the guy
from queer eye for the straight guy.
What's his name?
Ted Allen.
It's called chopped.
Is it all about salads?
No,
they get baskets at the beginning.
It's actually,
it was actually a good show for about a
month until it became like a gay cause
of every episode.
Is a transgender guy going,
I'm going to take the $10,000,
get myself a pussy and I get my,
my uncle,
a pair of tits and uh,
I'm sorry.
I put too much lemon in the homies.
I'm serious.
And I know Ryan.
I know 10 Allen.
I met him at a roast.
I like them.
I'm just saying when people talk about,
you know,
everything's gate up on TV.
That show is a perfect example.
It up.
Oh my God.
And again,
that's not,
I'm not saying anything against gay
people.
I'm just saying.
But,
but that show is what would piss people
off.
You know,
I get it till you sorta.
Yeah,
I know what you.
I mean,
I get a sensitive to people that attack
your own ideas.
Like when people,
when someone,
someone's like,
Seth Meyers is attacking your ideas.
My ideas make it up a bunch of fucking
real soft jokes about trump.
He had one very good bit that he did
recently where they were talking about
the ban the ban on immigrants.
Like when they were like,
no one is saying ban.
It's not a band.
We've never used the word ban.
And then he cuts to a clip,
a montage of trump and all the other
saying that you could go to any
politician.
It's just fucking cheap trickery,
but not as much as I used to like um,
but,
but I think NBC sat him down and said,
you gotta go fucking.
You got to be the point man on this.
We think so.
Oh,
I do.
I've never had a sat down having been
sat down.
I've never had a sat down and I sat
down.
Yeah,
will never.
No one's ever sat me down.
Oh No.
No one's ever sat me down and said,
hey,
you got to go this way.
That's never happened.
Literally ever.
Well,
of course not because you are a
mushrooms and you lift weights.
They're not going to accuse you.
Shoot an elk on the one slash nine out
of the back of the bow and Arrow who the
who the fuck gonna tell you to do
anything.
Go.
But people accuse you if you have an
idea and you run with a cause,
they accuse you of being sat down by the
elite.
So of course I think that point they
didn't know it is probably how he feels.
So why would they sit them down if you
already know it feels that way.
And BC does that.
They never did when I was on.
Why would they do it with you?
But no one ever sits.
I don't think people sit.
Anybody down.
I you don't.
I know they do,
but if you ever experienced not,
not let's.
I know you've taken me literally hit 10
years.
They get points from the New York Times
and oh by the way,
seth is funny and he's a likable guy.
Matter of fact,
when he first had his late night show,
I go,
he could be a tonight show host.
She's likable.
She'll spend the 10 minutes.
I can't fucking watch a closer look.
And it's 40 trump jokes.
Well,
it's low hanging fruit.
It's not easy to make fun of trump.
Yes it is.
Trump jokes and you're a site.
Yeah,
I know what he said.
Absolutely.
I want you to do your act what you do
your rack,
but you criticize him.
I,
I do.
I said he made it look too easy.
Number one,
he was just telling people what they
want her to hear.
What I was running fucking trump a
little bit about your healthcare plan.
Well,
but the skinniest people alive.
The next question,
any followups?
No.
Next question about Baba,
you know,
and uh,
was the fucking fine?
Yeah.
There's no way you can deport 11 million
people.
Have you seen the size of my jet?
Three trips but,
but you know,
I fucking take shots at them.
That's not really.
Yeah.
Oh,
what are you a fucking night?
You're,
you're,
you're on the left.
The left.
So you don't have a bunch of shit on
him.
I didn't say I did.
I like what he's doing.
Do you like the wall?
I can build the wall.
I think the idea that people who,
if you say you,
I want to protect our borders,
makes you a racist.
That's some real left wing stupidity
right there.
Hm?
Yeah.
Left wing's stupidity.
Do you know California?
Jerry Brown.
Nancy Pelosi Berkeley.
Do you think he's stupid?
Name is ever going to come?
A time where there won't be any walls,
there won't be any borders.
And everyone literally go anywhere they
want.
Not.
I don't know what the word lab work like
that ever,
but how do you know what mean humanity?
Because people are psychotic,
but how can we can do that here?
How come people can buy this country
held to a different standard when it
comes to that shit?
Why don't you try sneaking into Mexico,
see what's happened to you,
where the cat you invite people from all
over the world will let us go into
Mexico like that.
Oh,
you know that you could just drive to
Mexico,
you know that.
Right?
Have you ever done any gun illegally?
I'm just driving into my point.
If you try to sneak in.
Right?
But,
but my point is when you try to go down
to Mexico,
they didn't even stop you,
so you believe is dry,
so you don't believe in borders.
You think that could actually work?
I think that there's an even watching
what's going on in Europe right now.
Well,
that's a problem for sure,
but I think part of the reason that's a
problem is that culturally the places
these people are coming from are archaic
and that's something that the left
doesn't want to admit and I'm with them
100 percent and it's a real problem
because what's interesting,
but here's the problem.
That's right.
It is right.
Please.
All cultures aren't equal.
Never were.
No,
they're not only the.
That's the left main tenant was a goal,
but those.
What's interesting to me is that those
cultures that are the problem,
they're uncredible massage.
Right.
And we're ready to fucking feminist
yelling at them.
And if you.
If you say anything about those year
Islamophobia and you're a right wing
hate monger,
but you're talking about cultures that
are incredibly restrictive of women's
Bible.
Yeah.
It looks like 11 a.
I always say that,
but that's my point.
And even Bill Maher pointed it out.
Yeah.
He was yelling at the left,
the feminist.
Where are you yelling at trump?
Because he loves to grab pussy.
Meanwhile they lopping off heads because
a girl shows their ankle.
It's true.
It's like that's what I'm talking about.
I'm not a huge.
You're trying to make me have to be like
a huge trump.
I'm not,
but I'm saying at one point in time
we'll take the watchers like that,
but at one point in time that was the
norm,
like 2000,
3000 years ago.
That was a normal worldwide.
Right?
I mean there was a,
there was a restrictive policies against
women and things along those lines.
That was the norm worldwide.
I guess.
So.
So how is it not that you are right now
in California because people progress
and evolve.
So don't you think she can progress
involve worldwide to the point where we
don't have to have right now.
That wasn't even a question.
It's a long time.
Well,
my question is will there be a time
where people can just go everywhere and
you said you don't think the world works
that way.
I really don't.
People all flawed as a species.
We're definitely fly the
species here in California.
It's never going to change.
You could drive to sonoma right now.
No one's gonna stop you.
You don't have to show your papers.
I feel like there's gotta be a come a
time in history where human beings are
allowed to travel freely wherever they
want to go live,
wherever they want to go,
and the only thing that's stopping that
is it.
Some places are far less far less
prosperous than we are here.
So
what it states deeper and not just
prosperous.
It's because like you said,
you're seeing what's going on in Europe
and it's not fucking working.
It's not as close to open borders as
you're going to get well.
So
and a lot of these other countries,
they got a little silly and they thought
the rest of the world is like them and
they just let all these immigrants in
instantaneously with this,
but my point is not that we should let
everybody in and just let do whatever
you want.
My point is that at some point in time,
that's got to be the way the world works
where you could literally go anywhere
you want and then I don't think.
I think you know,
like the Tower of Babel and the idea
that one point in time people spoke one
language and then the God decided they
were getting too crazy and then he split
them up,
but all over the world and gave them a
bunch of different languages to never
communicate with each other.
It seems to me that if human beings
continue along the path that we're on
now,
how long it takes,
whether it's 5,000
years or whatever,
we're going to come to a point in time
where we have a universal language and
it might be within our grandchildren's
lifetime where people are allowed to
communicate with people all over the
world and if technology can evolve our,
our,
our cultures to the point where these
people that live in these unbelievably
restrictive environments and communities
can get to the point where they're like
the United States.
We have disagreements,
but you're free to go wherever you want.
I mean,
that's gotta be the future.
That's what I think.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but that doesn't make him a racist for
wanting to protect our borders and
that's at notch.
He's at nap,
fascist.
Nazi goes not doing anything bad.
This look at a view of life that's the
fire left.
Their ideas work great on paper.
Everybody agrees with them.
Yes,
they should be open,
but it just,
like you said,
everybody should be able to live
together and that all make sense to toe
the rubber hits the road.
It sounds good technically and it will
eventually.
Hopefully they'll get there,
but I'm just saying you can't label
people fascist and a racist that want to
fucking protect the water.
I agree with you.
Somebody who loves lead,
he knows because they are like Italians
to me.
They look like I'm not just Latinos now
we have Central America and the whole
world coming and Canadian.
I'm Canadian,
so I'm half Canadian.
French Canada.
You know what's really fucked up is that
it's really easy to come over here from
Syria.
It's really hard to come over from
Canada.
They've made it more difficult for
places.
Other places that are like almost offer
zero problems to.
To emigrate to America.
Like if you're a Canadian and you tried
to get a job in America,
good luck.
I know a lot of people that are
Canadians that you've got to plan,
you've got to marry somebody.
You got to find some chick.
Yeah.
And the hook it up,
you know?
Good Canadian boy.
Come on over here.
Or a good Canadian girl.
Yeah.
Not
that hard to,
to,
to come here from Syria.
I mean Obama
was busting people to cities and
dropping them off without even telling
the mayors and shit.
That's all you know.
Really.
Oh yeah.
He was doing it himself.
Did he drive the bows?
His.
It was his.
Was his idea of executive orders?
Yes.
How?
What did,
how did that order go?
Do you know what the order was?
Oh,
now now you're getting almost asking.
I don't know.
Well,
I've never heard this before.
Aca and all that stuff is questionably
on constantly.
You didn't hear about it exactly because
the media wouldn't cover it.
If you go online and talking to mayors
in Pennsylvania,
schools are being,
you know,
we're one place was overwhelmed.
Lynn,
Massachusetts schools are being
overwhelmed by kids who,
you know,
have been here for five minutes.
Brilliant.
Lot of unconstitutional shit went on.
You know,
I never heard about that.
I'm not making it up.
It was so many things going on in the
world.
It's impossible to be abreast of all
that.
Absolutely.
That's what I'm saying.
Just it's not that hard.
I'm saying,
you know,
so we just got so lucky.
That's the problem in America.
We got so fucking lucky geographically.
Oh the luckiest.
Yeah.
But you know what?
That's all changed.
How so?
What do you mean plane?
They can fly over now.
They don't have to fucking,
you know,
but that's all changed.
Nine slash 11 or trying to get.
I'm in a long time ago,
I'm just saying you were right for years
because of a.
We were at geographically with two
oceans will not just bought.
It's things like flight and.
But it's also the spot itself,
like just having the opportunity you
have here in America.
It's so unusual.
No caste system.
Like we were talking about India yet
yet.
Yet all you hear is how racist isn't and
homophobic yet people,
both black and brown people are trying
to sneak in a.
is that,
is that all you hear?
Is that America,
America's racist if you watch TV,
mainstream media.
Yeah.
That's all you hear.
I don't.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
I know you don't want to yet.
You exactly.
I don't watch programming the trend of
program.
You think the mainstream media is like
an has a left slant to it at all?
I definitely.
Did they admit that?
I definitely do,
and that's what people get their
information.
Yeah.
No.
Well,
if you're on the right,
you have to feel pretty alienated by the
media because the mainstream media,
which is primarily in New York and La,
California,
those are these big central locations
for liberal thinking.
Yeah.
Isn't it weird though that when you get
big giant groups of people together,
they become liberal is weird.
How so?
Predominantly like New York dominantly
liberal.
California's predominantly liberal.
Those are the population centers of the
country.
They're also the education centers of
the country.
It's really fascinating to me that when
you,
and even in Chicago,
Chicago's kind of predominantly liberal
as well,
yet they lost the election,
but it was,
but isn't it strange though?
I mean I understand.
I'm not saying a bubble who don't hang
around with other people.
It's bad,
but.
But why is it though that when you get
giant clumps of people that have to live
together in huge groups,
they primarily liberal.
What's interesting cities in the midwest
that aren't,
you know,
but what?
That aren't liberal named one.
Yeah.
Like what?
I don't know it.
That's not the Midwest.
I know.
I was trying to think of the midwest
myself.
It was the middle school.
I was liberal but.
But it's also.
Is there man?
No.
I know he wore a dress,
but I sell out of Minneapolis.
They love me.
Tow.
I bet they do.
There's plenty of people.
That's what I'm saying.
You're a funny guy.
You know you'd sell out in New York.
What the fuck you talking about?
You know.
No,
I don't.
You know,
you will now know when you put on the
robe.
I go,
it's the belly of the beast.
Find a fucking Nyu students.
What are you shitting me?
All the Nyu students are hilarious.
All students.
Hilarious.
How about college campuses?
That seems pretty fair.
What goes on there?
I have a friend of mine who goes to Nyu
and she sent me this.
Um,
this thing that was abolishing whiteness
was a.
oh,
I covered that on my podcast.
Abolishing whiteness.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a class and almost every college
now.
That's what I'm talking about.
How's that fair?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know how it was a pharaoh.
It's not.
It just seems to me that there's just
too much us versus them.
And that's where real part of the
problem.
Media is.
That immediate way.
Of course,
that's part of the media.
Why are you so are you,
you're,
you're in a slight way.
You're doing it very softly,
but how so?
Oh,
you're a lefty,
but you think I am.
Well,
just get you eat.
Elk doesn't make you a fucking right.
But what makes me a righty?
What would I have to do know?
What would make you a righty?
What?
What would make me a lefty buck and
paying for punching somebody I disagree
with spot.
That's tough.
You'd calm down.
That's why I would.
If I didn't have this generator first
and I had to rely on my neighbor's man,
I just say,
I just drank a quarter.
Your coffees fired,
whatever,
but what makes it a little bit,
but what are the primary things?
I don't know.
Labels.
People writing me.
Not Yo,
your side.
My side.
My Newton.
Newton.
Where you grew up?
False.
Blue collar.
What's up or falls?
I know.
The poor area.
Would they make only out in 40 grand?
That's a poor part of noting.
Just imagine this is a place where
people average 140 grand a week.
Imagine it's called Apple.
Anybody who works in Cupertino is that
nice up there?
Beautiful Kid got attacked by a mountain
lion last year though.
That's part of the problem with
liberals.
Didn't want to kill mountain lions,
so that's why I'm not on their side with
that issue.
Exactly.
It was a bunch of.
That's how you protect the border with
fucking online.
Mexicans know how to handle mountain.
I know gonna be scared of them.
Yeah.
Then that's doing 10 minutes.
Eat.
I'm good.
Backstrap cook them up.
The Mountain Lion Loins tastes like pork
is really good.
Lion.
No,
but I know a friend of mine was shot
one.
He says delicious.
Sarah's.
Yeah.
What is it malicious,
really a wolf.
Have you had.
Well,
no I haven't,
but uh,
Steve Rinella who was on the podcast is
a very famous hunter and author and
historian.
He was telling me that there was this
famous mountain man and a wolf was his
favorite meal.
You like to eat wolf?
Yeah.
Terrorists.
Guys to shoot wolves and eat them.
But I wonder if his faction faction of
eating a wolf because you know,
it could eat you like that's probably
what I figured you would be drinking a
wolf's blood and shit.
I'm going to be bear.
I've eaten a lot of bear.
Right.
You probably.
And you do it for like reasons like the
Japanese he chocked fens.
You want the county and the vitality of
seat and Rhino.
Dicks and shit.
No,
they,
they should bear because they have to
because there's so many bear and they
buried all the mix and if some guy,
and I'm not,
it's funny now he has robbed,
not like a fucking righty,
like when I was younger I'd killed
pheasants and Shit and my grandmother
would cook and I'd shoot rabbits and
shit like that.
As I get older though,
as you get older you appreciate,
you know,
I mean when I see people shooting,
taking down a giant elephant,
safari is really hard to kill an
elephant.
I could walk up to it and stabbed to
death.
You definitely couldn't fucking kill
you.
Throw you it.
How hard is it to hit an elephant with a
gun,
Joe?
Not very hard.
Or you get a moose?
Well,
Moza delicious.
And uh,
I,
I don't get close to it.
You couldn't shoot a moose.
I could like,
there's so many dare my where I live,
I could suffocate them with demos.
I could,
I could stop here with the dry cleaning
bag and my back.
Well you have a lot of Moose in.
There are a lot of deer in your area,
right?
That area is overrun.
Okay.
Be careful of ticks,
right?
Don't just lyme disease.
I got it.
And you get lyme disease.
I had the tick.
I had the big bullseye on my back and my
wife got it.
Buck and luckily we caught it early,
but I go by Johnny [inaudible] by John.
His wife got lyme disease.
It's fucking dangerous,
man.
I know.
10 people that have it.
I have to check my boss before I go to
bed every night for texts.
Yeah,
in the summertime.
Well they give you an antiseptic.
That's what's weird.
Ticks.
They have like antiseptic saliva.
So then when you're biting you,
you don't even feel it.
Right.
Creepy little fuckers,
man.
And there's diseases.
They say that in the.
Somewhere in New York there was some,
some place like near Long Island where
they tested the ticks and they found
that 60 percent of the ticks had lyme
disease.
Six zero.
That's fucking insane.
It was insane.
Yeah.
My wife's knee blow up.
She got this big fucking.
So did she take the antibiotics and
declare it all that shit because we
caught it quick.
People you don't even know.
We're not a guy on our podcast.
Steve Kotler and he had lyme disease for
a fucking year before they diagnosed it
and it fucked him up so bad that he was
in the hospital for three years,
three years from lyme disease.
Remember that?
Jamie will.
Yeah.
Scary.
My wife had to walk around with like an
IB thing.
Oh Jesus Christ.
And uh,
no.
It's like a silent epidemic in this
country.
Those goddamn and come off the fucking
deer that come off the deal.
Look so cute and shit.
Yeah.
But it's terrifying.
When I shot that deer in Colorado,
we found a bunch of ticks on it.
We got to be super careful cleaning it
up.
Oh,
is that right?
Yeah.
We found ticks like nearest balls and
shit.
You have to be careful.
Ticks,
love balls won't fix her.
Gross man.
They just fucking creepy little animals
that have this bizarre disease that we
were fairly recent.
I know it's a recent disease.
I mean it's,
it's not,
it's not that it's probably been around
right,
but they didn't know what it was back in
the day.
I don't think they think that.
No,
they think that it's something that is
a,
something created by the right.
There's a bunch of conspiracy theories
about lyme disease.
Yeah.
It's definitely could pay and completed
by the right because it affects mostly
white people.
That's why there's too many of us.
It depends.
Group.
Oh,
read that book.
I'm scared.
Sarah Z.
I'm never voting again.
So what do you just think that it's all
a scam?
Toe Drain it.
It's not a scam.
It's planned.
The fucking,
the rockefellers.
They are the ones at the heart of all
this shit selling to the book.
Trump is involved in it and he doesn't
know it so far.
They think ahead.
You know Bill Hicks's bit right about.
Just pop it on the left.
No,
I knew the puppet on the right is one
guy controlling both puppets.
Book makes that crystal fucking clear.
Will look at you.
Your eyes are bulging tense.
It's like I get an eight ball with this
fucking rocket fuel.
You put in me,
don't drink one of these,
whatever you do.
No,
I can't say that.
Seventy milligrams caffeine and that'll
make me cry in the plant and I got a
beat it soon.
Okay.
[inaudible].
I got my car.
Jerry Sandusky.
Son Jeffrey charged with child sexual
abuse.
Oh,
runs in the family.
Of course it does.
He probably did it to his own kid.
More than five.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's terrifying.
Did that just come out a jam 11 minutes
ago?
God,
that's so terrible.
I was supposed to go bowling with him
next week.
Criminal solicitation and corruption of
minors.
14 counts.
Oh God.
He's 41.
Jesus Christ.
That's so gross.
How many comps?
14.
That's probably all they caught him with
his old man's like,
hey,
couldn't keep up with me.
You're lacking like every other kid.
Got It.
Easy.
You got it.
Good.
So he's going away should.
But that's the crazy thing about child
sexual molestation that it seems to
affect the kids and the kids wind up
doing it.
It's like what you just said it pro.
We don't know for a fact,
but you're probably right.
Yeah,
sure.
He got dead old.
I'm sure his dad was so fucking piece of
shit.
He probably fucked him too.
He probably fucked everybody,
but he knew a three,
four defense.
I'll tell you.
Did He,
was he good at it?
I don't know.
He was there for years though.
It's tuned to watching on the sideline.
It's too bad job.
Paternal dot.
I would like to have known what he knew
about two minutes after he retired.
He was,
was actually lucky we didn't get the
grill rest must have been like.
Absolutely.
You know,
and the guy that age took down a statue
and all that shit and realize that like
his whole legacy
was tainted by being connected to this
fucking criminal.
And then they replaced the statue with
peewee Herman.
That was kind of a dig at them or
anything.
So the joke.
Yeah,
thyroid.
Jamie got it.
And look at these fucking laughed.
What do you tell a producer not to laugh
out loud.
Funny laughs and everything.
It's constantly laughing.
I just didn't know what you're saying.
I was confused.
Yes.
Peewee Herman's a stature and Penn
state.
He's got to be a statue somewhere.
Google statue of peewee Herman.
I bet it's up somewhere.
It's right in front of the cub scouts
building.
Ben,
when he got arrested for beating off in
a theater,
who hasn't done that?
That's the old school way theaters and
beat off.
I liked John so much.
I dragged off during jazz.
When a cop that arrest someone for doing
that.
Did you go to jail for misappropriation
of public funds?
You're a jerk.
You're arresting people for jerking off
at a porno theater.
Which what do you want to.
I thought he was at the lowest cineplex.
Did you really?
I didn't know it was a bond.
No.
He went to a goddamn gay porno theater
for.
For Christ's.
Exactly,
but apparently people were getting upset
that other regular folks couldn't just
go and watch guys watch each other in
the mouth and not pull the ticks out.
What kind of business are you running
here?
Whose men masturbating and somebody had
to fire off an email to the theater
manager.
Well,
you know what it is as low hanging
fruit.
It's like they just decided to arrest
someone they needed,
uh,
needed to get a collar and that's how
they did it.
Yeah.
I think depaul you have to leave.
Were you,
uh,
were CSO is when.
Tell us when CSOS.
My special,
uh,
is premiering this Thursday night.
Uh,
it's called inflammatory.
It's on Cecil where and for you and a
advil required legend gentleman.
But here's the big thing,
Joe,
my podcast which is on itunes and riot
gas,
um,
on Mondays for free.
But if you want to subscribe,
you go to connect pal.com/nick.
What is this subscribing do?
And they get two to three more shows a
week straight and then you'll have more
people coming to.
This is working out because that's money
you have.
I have to do what I gotta do I
understand what you're saying.
I have a coke a thing with Henry Hill
and Pittsburgh.
It's going to wealth connect
pal.com/nick
and you can sign up and people are
loving it.
Nick d dot Com for all this information,
you can get it@nicdip.com
and see.
So Thursday night,
Thursday night is the prayer of my,
when I was special and CSO by the way.
One hundred percent support.
CSO.
CSO is the shit.
They're doing amazing stuff.
They have so many.
They have stan hope has this special
there.
Joey Diaz as a special there.
It's fucking phenomenal.
Janine did one and a special out.
She had one a few months ago.
Shelley.
Her only piece of work.
Like standup.
Yeah.
She doesn't have a body of work.
That was always the criticism.
Well,
I think she has one and a dude.
I really don't want to wait a year.
I just hate traveling so much.
Anytime,
man.
Anytime.
Anytime we can do it,
we could try it through skype.
She wanted to do it that way.
Yeah,
I did that with Steven crowder.
You got to be here.
I don't get to see him Thursday night.
Nick Depaul on the best comics in the
world without a doubt.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate it.
And do it again.
Thank you so much.
Fun.
Alright,
see you tomorrow.
Fuckers.